GOOD AFTERNOON I'M GOING TO
MAKE SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS
TODAY TO EXPLAIN THE PROCESSES
THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED TO
CONTINUE OUR ESSENTIAL WORK
DURING THE PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE
OF YOU FAMILIAR WITH THE
PROCESS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE WHILE I GO THROUGH IT
AGAIN FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE
TUNING IN FOR THE FIRST TIME.
SO LET ME COVER SOME OF THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
TODAY. IN RESPONSE TO COBIT
NINETEEN A MERCHANT SEE IN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING.
AND IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC. HAS ACCESS TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. BY
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IT IN A
WAY THAT PROTECTS THE HALTH
AND SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND
OUR EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR IT
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN MULTIPLE TIMES
TODAY. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX ZERO NINE.
AND IT IS ON THE SCREEN AGAIN
WILL REPEAT IT A COUPLE TIMES
THROUGHOUT THE HEARING. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY WILL OPEN YOUR
LINE AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
FEEDBACK YOU MUST BE YOU THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHIN THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO YOUR
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU. AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN INDIA
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OUR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS.
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES. FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW ONLINE
TOOLS SO AGAIN PLEASE BE
PATIENT SO EVERYONE CAN BE
HEARD. AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
INCREDIBLE STENOGRAPHER I WANT
TO ASK ALL SPEAKERS INCLUDING
MY COLLEAGUES AND WITNESSES
ALIKE TO SPEAK SLOWLY AND
CLEARLY. HAVING SAID ALL OF
THIS BEFORE WE BEGIN TODAY'S
AGENDA WE SHOULD ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND AS A REMINDER TO
MEMBERS- YOU'LL NEED TO TURN ON
YOUR MICROPHONE FOR THE ROLL
CALL AND EVERY TIME WE VOTE.
MATT MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GROVE HERE ROOF
HERE KAMLAGER. YOUR LONGER HERE
LAYERED HERE WE'RE HERE FAITH
HERE BATES HERE ATKINS HERE
ATKINS HERE THANK YOU- LET ME
START OFF BY WELCOMING OUR
NEWEST MEMBER OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE SENATOR SYDNEY
KAMLAGER WELCOME. WE ARE
THRILLED TO HAVE YOU HERE AND-
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND-
DISPENSE WITH A COUPLE OF QUICK
ITEMS I WOULD ASK OUR MY
COLLEAGUES IF SOMEONE WOULD BE
PREPARED TO MAKE. A MOTION ON
ITEM TWO F. THAT'S THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR IN THAT
WOULD BE MISS WENDY MITCHELL.
MEMBER OF THE HORSE RACING
BOARD AND AS A REMINDER TO
FOLKS WE ACTUALLY- APPROVED AND
CONFIRMED- MISS MITCHELL IN
AUGUST I BELIEVE SO- WE'VE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO QUESTION HER
AT LENGTH AND SO FELT IT
APPROPRIATE THAT SHE'D BE ON
THE NOT REQUIRED TO APPEAR LIST
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE TWO OTHER
MEMBERS. IN THE AGENDA FOR
MEMBERS OF THAT BOARD I WOULD
MOVE APPROVAL OF SAID EARLIER
THANK YOU A MOTION BY HIM-
MADAM SECRETARY WILL BE CALL
THE ROLL. GROSS I. WROTE I.
LONGER I AM LONGER I'D LAYERED
HI THERE I YES ALL RIGHT IF AYE
CAN FIND INSIDE FIVE. THANK YOU
FIVE TO AND I ALSO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER THREE
REFERENCE OF BILLS TO COMMITTEE
SO MOVE THANK YOU MR LAYERED-
MA'AM SECRETARY WE CALL THE
ROLL ROAD HIGH GROWTH I
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER EYES GLARED
HI THERE I BATES HI IF I CAN HI
I CAN SIGN. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES ALSO FIVE TWO ZERO
WITH THAT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
MOVE TO- ITEM NUMBER ONE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR ONE A AND THAT WOULD
BE FOR DR- FILANTE RIDDLE
COMMISSIONER TO THE BOARD OF
JUVENILE HEARINGS. AND I THINK
PRIOR TO HER MAKING COMMENTS WE
GIVE A COURTESY TO OUR
COLLEAGUES TO ASK IF THEY COULD
BE HERE TO. MAKE OPENING
COMMENTS SO I'M GOING TO
WELCOME SENATOR STEVE BRADFORD
UP FIRST- CENTER BRADFORD I'M
SORRY I'D- I WILL ASK UP MY
CAUCUS CHAIR. SENATOR LEYVA TO
COME UP AND MAKE COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
ALL MEMBERS IT IS AN ABSOLUTE
PLEASURE FOR ME TO BE HERE
TODAY AND SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
DOCTOR FULL ON TAPE RENTAL. I
MET DR RIDDLE WHEN SHE WAS
RUNNING FOR THE SENATE A FEW
YEARS AGO AND I WAS STRUCK BY
ONE HER STRONG PERSONALITY I
LOVE A WOMAN WITH A STRONG
PERSONALITY. BUT THAT STRONG
PERSONALITY WAS ALSO THERE WAS
A CARING PINE THE GENUINE
SPIRIT SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY
CARED ABOUT THE COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY GENUINELY. SOMEONE
WHO SPENT TWENTY NINE YEARS IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT IS STILL
WORRIED ABOUT SOCIAL JUSTICE
AND POLICE REFORM. I CAN'T
THINK OF SOMEONE BETTER TO BE
ON THE BOARD OF JUVENILE
HEARINGS I KNOW SHE'S BEEN
SERVING IN THE POSITION ALREADY
AND HOPEFULLY YOU WILL CONFIRM
HER TODAY. SHE HAS AN AMAZING
WORK ETHIC SHE HAS AN UPBEAT
AND POSITIVE ATTITUDE WHEN SHE
DID NOT WIN HER SENATE SEAT IT
DID NOT GET HER DOWN SHE FOUND
ANOTHER WAY TO GIVE BACK TO OUR
COMMUNITY BY WORKING WITH THE
YWCA IN AN EXECUTIVE POSITION.
I FIND HER TO BE A VERY
PRINCIPLED AND PERSON AND A
PERSON OF FAITH. I FIND HER TO
BE VERY COOPERATIVE AND A HEART
THAT IS GENERALLY FOCUSED ON
HELPING OTHERS. HE'S ALSO A
MOTIVATIONAL SPEAKER FOR THOSE
OF YOU HO DOES DO NOT KNOW THE
TOPICS SHE COVERS OR SOCIAL
JUSTICE POLICE REFORM PUBLIC
SAFETY MENTAL HEALTH.
DEVELOPING LEADERSHIP SKILLS
GENDER EQUITY AND MENTORING I
COULDN'T THINK OF SOMEONE
BETTER TO FILL THE SPOT ON THE
HEARING BOARD FOR JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND I WOULD. ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONFIRM HER TODAY THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME GIVE A FEW
COMMENTS THANK YOU SENATOR
LEYVA. SENATOR. BRADFORD
WELCOME. THANK YOU MADAM
PROTERRA MEMBERS A STERLING
HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY AND
ENTER TO STOP REPLYING TO A
RENTAL. A LEADER A CRITICAL
THINKER AND A CIVIC MINDED
BLACK WOMAN WAS GIVEN SO MUCH
OF HERSELF TO HER COMMUNITY.
SHE'S SINCE BEEN STATED BEEN A
HARD WORKER CAN COMMITTED TO
WORKING AROUND A VARIETY OF
ISSUES THAT IMPACT NOT ONLY
AFTER AMERICAN COMMUNITY BUT
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I PERSONALLY KNOWN
MISS RENTAL WELL BEFORE I MET
HER PERSONALLY BECAUSE AT ONE
POINT THE CITY OF GARDENA WAS
IN SEARCH OF A NEW POLICE CHIEF
AND HER NAME. HAD RISEN TO ON
THE SHORT LIST. I ADMIRE DR-
FOR HER INTELLIGENCE AND HER
GIVING NATURE AND FULLY SUPPORT
FOR CONFIRMATION TO THE
JUVENILE PAROLE BOARD. SHE WILL
BRING A BROAD UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE TO THIS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT BOARD AS SHE HAS DONE
SO FAR IN HER ASSIGNMENT
DOCTOROW'S SPENT MOST OF HER
CARESS STATED TWENTY NINE YEARS
AS A POLICE OFFICER
INVESTIGATOR. SERGEANT
LIEUTENANT PUBLIC INFORMATION
OFFICER AND- TO THE CHIEF OF
POLICE TO THE PASADENA POLICE
DEPARTMENT. I'M ALWAYS ON MY
BEST BEHAVIOR AROUND HER.
DOCTORAL STARTED OUR OWN
BUSINESS IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN IT WAS A PRIMARY. THAT
THE FILANTE RENTAL LEADERSHIP
CONSULTANT IN ADDITION A
DOCTORAL BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATIVE EXPERIENCE
EXTENSIVE LEGISLATIVE
EXPERIENCE FROM TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN TO NINETEEN SHE WORKED
AS A FIELD REPRESENTATIVE THEN
DISTRICT DIRECTOR AND FINALLY
AS EXTERNAL EXTERNAL AFFAIRS
CONSULTANT TO ASSEMBLYMAN CHRIS
HOLDEN IN ADDITION SHE ASSISTED
THE CAUCUS IN MANY LEGISLATIVE.
ACTIVITIES ENOUGH TO
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND
SOCIAL ISSUES AND EVENTS.
DOCTOROW IS A GRADUATE OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMAND COLLEGE AND
FBI NATIONAL ECONOMY O'CLOCK
QUINTANA QUINTANA CALLED
VIRGINIA. HE EARNED A DOCTORATE
DEGREE IN PSYCHOLOGY FROM
PHILLIPS GRADUATE INSTITUTE AND
A MASTERS OF ARTS DEGREE IN
ORDER NAY IN ORGANIZATIONAL
LEADERSHIP FROM WOODBURY
UNIVERSITY. I RESPECTFULLY URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
DOCTOROW AND THANK THE PROTEIN
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO AND
INTRODUCED THIS INCREDIBLE
WOMAN. THANK YOU THANK YOUSO
MUCH SENATOR BRADFORD AND- WITH
THAT LET ME TURN IT OVER TO YOU
DOCTOR RIDDLE ARE. QUITE AN
OPENING THAT WE DON'T TYPICALLY
HAVE A COMMITTEE BUT- IT DOES
HAPPEN AND SO HIGH PRAISE FROM
TWO OF OUR COLLEAGUES. LET ME
INVITE YOU TO INTRODUCE.
YOURSELF ANYONE WITH YOU THAT
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
MAKE SOME OPENING COMMENTS AND
THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS SO WELCOME DOCTOR
RENTAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
AM I APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BEFORE THE
RULES COMMITTEE AND I THANK
YOU- I DON'T TRUST HIM I AM. M.
HUMBOLDT AND I AM GRATEFUL FOR
SENATOR LEYVA AND BRADFORD FOR
SPEAKING ON MY BEHALF I THINK
THEY JUST GAVE ME MY FOR
RESUMES. YOU CAN NOW HAVE TO GO
DOWN THAT ROAD BUT I ALSO WANT
TO JUST SAY- I HAVE. BEEN
PREPARING FOR THIS POSITION
LONG BEFORE I EVEN KNEW IT
EXISTED QUITE FRANKLY- AND THEY
HAVE ALREADY THAT THE TWO
SENATORS HAVE SPOKEN TO THAT I
WANT TO INTRODUCE STAR MY
HUSBAND OF FORTY THREE YEARS
HAS BEEN ON THIS JOURNEY WITH
ME- AND WE ARE. COMMITTED TO
THEIR STYLE HE HAS GOT A FIRST.
HAND VIEW NOW OF SINCE THE-
PANDEMIC BECAUSE I FRANKLY I'M
WORKING FROM HOME LIKE MANY
INDIVIDUALS AND SO HE HAS SEEN
WHAT IT TAKES AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO HELPING. AS MANY
OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AS WE CAN
NOW SPEND THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES NEXT FIFTY YEARS OF THEIR
LIVES IN IN IN CUSTODY AND HAVE
A PRODUCTIVE LIFE AND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS. AND
I'M READY TO- BEFORE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR RIDDLE I AM GONNA IF
OKAY MADAM VICE CHAIR WOMAN
START WITH YOU. WILL WELCOME DR
RIDDLE AND- WE HAD A WONDERFUL
CONVERSATION EARLIER IN THE DAY
SO I TOLD YOU I DIDN'T REALLY
HAVE ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS OF
INCREDIBLE RESUME THAT I WANTED
YOU TO ELABORATE ON AND WE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS
BUT- IT IS BASICALLY- HELLO MY
LITTLE NOTES HERE. FINE DON'T.
WE TALKED ABOUT- YOU KNOW
FOLLOWING UP ON THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN RELEASED TO THE COMMUNITY
AND WOULD YOU THINK IT HELPFUL
IF WE COULD DEVELOP A SYSTEM
THAT WE COULD TRACK OF THEIR
PROGRESS AS THEY WENT AND THEY
WERE RELEASED INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND KNOW THAT THE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
DESIGNED FOR- OF GETTING THEM
BACK ON THE RIGHT TRACK WE'RE
WORKING AND WHAT ARE WHAT'S
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THAT BASED
ON YOUR- I GUESS DEEP IMMERSION
INTO THIS WHOLE ISSUE ON
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND CERTAINLY.
PROVIDING ON FOR I THINK WE
WERE TALKING EARLIER 92% YOU
KNOW FIND THEIR WAY BACK INTO
POLITE SOCIETY WE MIGHT COLLEGE
AT EIGHT PERCENT- KIND OF DO A
RETURN TRIP FOR A LITTLE YOU
KNOW BOOSTER SHOT I GUESS IN
THE END THE PROGRAM SPENT YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT AS WE TALK
ABOUT ANY NEW USE HE DID
INDICATE THAT THERE WASN'T
ANYTHING SPECIFIC IN TERMS OF
FINANCE AND DATA AT THE MOMENT
BUT HOW WE MIGHT GET SOME OF
THAT BECAUSE I THINK WE REALLY
WANT TO HOME IN. ON PROGRAMS
THAT ARE MAKING A DIFFERENCE
FOR THESE KIDS OF WHO WANTS TO
SEE A FOURTEEN FIFTEEN YEAR OLD
YOU KNOW ON THEIR WAY TO PRISON
BECAUSE THEY GET OFF ON THE
WRONG TRACK AND- SOMEHOW FIND A
WAY ON FRANKLY DON'T FIND THEIR
WAY- TO BEING ABLE TO BE
PRODUCTIVE AND ENJOY THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT OUR GREAT
NATION PROVIDE THE JUST SOME
THOUGHTS ON THAT I THINK WE HAD
A LITTLE CONVERSATION ABOUT IT
AND YOU THOUGHT YOU WOULD THINK
ABOUT HIM SOME THOUGHTS. ON IT
WOULD PROVIDE SOME THOUGHTS ON
IT. I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
DID HAVE A CAR. IS THAT THE
SHAPE THERE ARE. INSIDE AND IN
YOUR SUPPORT OF WHAT WHAT THE-
WHAT WORK IS BEING DONE TO HELP
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. AND SO YOU KNOW A
LOT OF WORK AS WE DISCUSSED
THOSE INTO HELPING. ARE YOU.
COMING TO TERMS FENDER GROW IN
THEIR COGNITIVE ABILITIES TO
PROCESS AND MAKE. HEALTHY
DECISIONS- VERSUS THE FAULTY
THINKING THAT THEY COMMITTEE J.
J. WITH. AN TO N. IN PARTICULAR
TO YOUR QUESTION. IT IS- AT
THIS PARTICULAR POINT WHEN
THERE'S A HAND OFF IF YOU WILL
TO PROBATION TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THERE'S ALWAYS- A-
GREAT EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT
THEY HAVE A SUPPORT SYSTEM
WRAPAROUND. OF PROGRAMS TO HELP
THEM TO RE ACCLIMATE TO THE
COMMUNITY WITH THAT BEING SAID.
D. J. J. IN PARTICULAR THE
COMMISSIONERS WE DON'T HAVE A
WE DON'T TRACK THEM. IN SO YOUR
OUR CONVERSATION IS WOULD IT
BE- BENEFICIAL TO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS AND NOT JUST FROM A
CURIOSITY YEAH WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE ISSUE- WHO REALLY MADE A
SIGNIFICANT. SHIFT IN THEIR
LIFE BUT MORE SO FROM HOW CAN
WE DO IT BETTER IF WE KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THIS
YOUTH. AND THEN ACTUALLY HAVE
SOME DATA TO MAKE IT- EVIDENCE
BASED AND SO AT THIS PARTICULAR
POINT- AND AS I SAID TO YOU
EARLIER. I'VE ONLY BEEN DOING
THIS- JOB NOW SINCE OCTOBER
TWENTY NINETEEN THE GOVERNOR
APPOINT ME BUT IT'S GIVING ME
SOME CLEAR INSIGHT. AND I FELT
THIS WAY BEFORE I. AS AN
OFFICER BEFORE I EVEN CAME
INTO- YOU KNOW AS A
COMMISSIONER WITH THE. J. J. IS.
ONCE WE HAVE THIS YOU. AND WE
IN A POOR THESE AND INTO THEM
AND WE HAVETHEM TREAT THEIR
THREE WE OFFEND. THEY NEED TO
BE MORE CO PARENTING VERSUS A
HAND OUT ONE OF THE BEST
PROGRAMS THAT I HAVE BEEN
WITNESS TO IS HOW IT'S DONE IN
SAN DIEGO AND I USE THAT AS AN
EXAMPLE BECAUSE EVEN WHEN THAT
THE USER HAS A HALF OF GOOD.
REENTRY PLAN WITH THEIR
FAMILIES WANTING TO RE ACCEPT
THEM OR THEY HAVE A GRANDPARENT
OR AUNT OR SOMEONE WHO- A. R.
C. WHICH IS YOU KNOW AND TIME
SAID THAT THERE'S SOME
CORRELATION TO HELP THEM
REESTABLISH IN SAN DIEGO THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE TO GO INTO THAT
TRANSITIONAL. A COMMUNITY WHERE
THEY ARE CONNECTED TO RESOURCES
AND WE ENSURE THEY ENSURE THAT
BEFORE THEY GO OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY BACK TO THEIR HOME
THEY HAVE. THEY HAVE THOSE OF
THOSE ARM SUPPORT SYSTEMS IN
PLACE SO THAT THEY DON'T FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS AND SO I
WOULD USE THAT AS AN EXAMPLE
BUT AS ALL THINGS AS A COST
FACTOR. BUT I AM TO ANSWER YOUR
PARTICULAR QUESTION YES I THINK
THAT WOULD BE. AWESOME TO HAVE
SOME FORM OF. DATA DRIVEN.
TRACKING SO THAT WE WOULD KNOW
HOW TO HELP THE THEN WHAT WE
COULD DO BETTER- AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THEM. THANK YOU
FOR THAT NOT TO RELENT
ABSOLUTELY ON I THINK I HEARD
YOU SAY WRAPAROUND AND I KNOW
THAT THE COUNTY WAS A LITTLE. A
STRETCH WHEN I WAS ON THE BOARD
WITH GETTING FUNDS FOR THAT BUT
I THINK THAT THAT'S WHAT WE
NEED TO PUT A LOT MORE AND
EMPHASIS IN TERMS OF ARE. YOU
KNOW BUDGET FOR ON CHRISTMAS-
FOR THE REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
THAT ARE OUT THERE AND REALLY
AMPLIFY FAT IN TERMS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SPENDING SO I WILL
CARRY THAT FLORIDIANS. IN MY
COUNTY FINAL SAN DIEGO'S REALLY
YOU KNOW DONE DONE THE JOB SO
FAR AND I KNOW ORANGE COUNTY
HAS ALSO THAT. WITH COAL THAT
IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT THAT THE
RESOURCES ARE THERE FOR THIS
PARTICULAR. YOU KNOW ISSUES SO
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND UP I KNOW YOU'LL DO
A GREAT JOB. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
I'M GONNA GO TO SENATOR COM
L'ARBRE NEXT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- HOW ARE YOU DOCTOR
RESULT. NUMBER THANK YOU. WELL
THAT'S A GOOD FOR- SO FIRST I
JUST WANT TO REFERENCE OF THE
LIST OF INDIVIDUALS WHO WROTE
LETTERS OF SUPPORT ON YOUR
BEHALF FOR THIS APPOINTMENT IT
IS QUITE M. NOT ONLY AN
ILLUSTRIOUS BUT DIVERSE LIST
AND I WAS WONDERING IF YOU
COULD SPEAK TO THAT TO THE
DIVERSITY OF LETTERS OF SUPPORT
THAT HAVE COME IN- FOR YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I AM AGAIN
I DON'T SAY THIS- YES THE DOOR
WORD OUT WHEN I AM HUMBLED- AT
THE- LIST OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
SUPPORT ME AND KNOWN ME FOR
YEARS I'LL START WITH- YOU KNOW
CONGRESSMAN- ADAM SCHIFF- WE
HAVE OVER TWENTY FIVE YEAR YOU
KNOW OUR FRIENDSHIP AND- I
APPRECIATE HIM TAKING THE
PERSONAL TIME TO WRITE A LETTER
ON MY BEHALF. AND THEN I'LL
CONGRESS WOMAN FROM HEARING
BASS AS WELL AS- JUDY CHU
FORMER SENATOR HERO LOU- WHO
ALSO WROTE A LETTER ON MY
BEHALF AND THEN MY HOMETOWN
COMMUNITY- YOU KNOW FORMER
MAYOR BILL GO BOGART WHO HAS
KNOWN ME OVER THIRTY YEARS AND
WORKED WITH ME- THROUGHOUT MY
TIME AS A POLICE OFFICER AND A
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE. AS WELL AS
THE CURRENT MAYOR VICTOR GORDO-
WHO HAS- NO ME JUST ABOUT THE
SAME AMOUNT OF TIME. AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE OTHERS THAT WROTE
LETTERS INCLUDING OTHER CHAIR
FOR A LOSS AND IS DEMOCRATIC
PARTY MARK GONZALEZ AND THE
REGIONAL ELEVEN ON DEMOCRATIC
PARTY OF MARK- MARC ROMMEL'S
AND THERE ARE OTHERS I'M NOT
I'M NOT BY ANY MEANS SLIDING
THEM BUT FOR SAKE OF TIME I
WANT TO THANK. THEM AND I
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT I AM GLAD THAT YOU
REFERENCE CONGRESS. ADAM SCHIFF
HE IS- FOR MANY WHO KNOW HIM A
STAUNCH ALLY TO THE L. G. B. T.
L. G. B. T. Q. COMMUNITY- AND I
SAY THAT BECAUSE I'M HOPING
THAT YOU CAN SORT OF EXPAND ON
YOUR- RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
BIOLA UNIVERSITY YOU KNOW I WAS
GIVEN A COUPLE OF ARTICLES.
THAT WERE WRITTEN ABOUT YOU AND
THIS APPOINTMENT AND THEY
REALLY CONTEXTUALIZE VIEW AS AN
ADVERSARY TO THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY AND I WAS WONDERING
IF YOU COULD. YOU KNOW SPEAK TO
THIS. RESHAPE THAT IN YOU KNOW
IT'S IF NO ONE ELSE WAS MORE
SHOCKED ME. WHEN I READ THOSE
STORIES WHICH WERE NOT- IMAGES
SAY THIS EASY TO DEHUMANIZE A
PERSON WE DON'T KNOW THEM AND
YOU DON'T KNOW THEIR STORY AND
THEIR ASSUMPTIONS MADE AND
SOMETIMES PEOPLE SMEAR OTHER
INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE- IT FITS
THEIR AGENDA. AND MY FAMILY HAS
ALWAYS AND I'LL START WITH MY
MOTHER WHO HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
STRONG ADVOCATE FOR TREATING
PEOPLE FAIRLY AND WITH RESPECT
AND DIGNITY AS SHE WAS FORCED
FROM HER HOME IN BIRMINGHAM
ALABAMA WHEN SHE WAS SEVENTEEN
YEARS OLD BECAUSE SHE WAS TOO
UPPITY. AND DIDN'T KNOW HER
PLACE AND- SHE AN INCORPORATED
ENOUGH THAT- YOU DON'T
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST PEOPLE.
ONE OF THE THINGS. THAT HAVE
BEEN- SHOCKING TO ME IS BECAUSE
I HAVE A DEEP FAITH. AND I
CHOSE I WAS RECRUITED TO TEACH
AT BIOLA BY THEN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR- I'M SORRY JESSE LEE.
AND HE ASKED ME IF I WOULD BE
WILLING TO TEACH THEIR BECAUSE
IT NEVER HAD AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN THEY NEVER HAD A
POLICE OFFICER TEACH THEIR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE PROGRAM. AND I
SAID YES FOR THE SAME REASON I
WENT INTO LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
AND PUT MY APPLICATION IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE IS
BECAUSE I WANTED TO HELP I
WANTED TO ENSURE THAT THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO WANT MONEY TO BECOME
POLICE OFFICERS PROBATION AND
PAROLE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
TAUGHT BY A YEAR- BLACK LAW
ENFORCEMENT MOMENT. WHO HAD
SEEN THE STRUGGLES AND WANTED
TO ENSURE THAT THEY UNDERSTOOD
THEIR ROLE AS US PUBLIC SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND NOT JUST
ENFORCEMENT AND SO I CHOSE TO
TEACH AT THAT SCHOOL TO HELP
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE A
LARGER VIEW. OF WHAT IT MEANT
TO BE A SERVICE AS A POLICE
OFFICER AND- I WAS TAKEN ABACK
WHEN I WAS CRITICIZED FOR I
WILL NEVER. COMPROMISE ANY
PUNCHES IT COMES TO HOW MY-
BECAUSE THIS GUY ME IN MY HOUSE
AND I CHILDREN SO A LOT OF THE
ADVERSARY SITUATIONS. BUT AS I
SHARED IN SOME OF MY INTERVIEWS
PRIOR TO THIS MEETING IS THAT
THE BIBLE HAS BEEN MISUSED FOR
GENERATIONS BUT WHAT I WAS TALK
FROM FROM GENERAL FROM- GENESIS
TO REVELATIONS. IS THAT THE
BIBLE HAS THREE HUNDRED PLUS
WORDS OF LOVE IN IT AND NOT TO
JUDGE OTHER PEOPLE AND YET IT
CONSISTENT BAY CONTINUOUSLY IF
MISUSED AND I'M NOT GOING TO
ALLOW ANYONE TO- TAKE THAT AWAY
FROM ME. BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN
TREATING PEOPLE WITH RESPECT
AND DIGNITY AND MY LIFE HAS
BEEN AN EXAMPLE OF THAT. THANK
YOU I HAVE ONE FINAL QUESTION
AND- USER TALKED A LOT ABOUT
JUDGMENT- AND FAIR TREATMENT-
AND I THINK THOSE ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT ASPECTS OF THIS
PARTICULAR COMMISSION AND THE
WORK THAT YOU ARE DOING AS A
COMMISSIONER YOU KNOW YOU AND I
TALKED A BIT ABOUT YOUR
HISTORY- ABOUT HOW YOU JOINED
THE FORCE- IN PASADENA. ABOUT
HOW IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT-
ABOUT HOW YOU WERE AN
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION HIRE AND
WE'RE SORT OF TREATED WITH
DISDAIN AND THERE WAS AN
EXPECTATION THAT YOU REALLY
WEREN'T QUALIFIED BUT YOU WERE
THERE BECAUSE THERE WAS A QUOTA
THAT NEEDED TO BE MAD ABOUT
HIRING A BLACK PERSON. AND SO-
AT ALSO GOT ME THINKING ABOUT
THE JUVENILES WHO ARE IN THE
SYSTEM WHO ARE ALSO DISREGARDED
AND DISRESPECTED AND TREATED
WITH DISDAIN. AND THE
EXPECTATION IS THAT THEIR
FAILURES AND THAT THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO DO IS TO SUCCEED AND
THAT MAYBE WE SHOULD BE
INVESTING RESTORATIVE EFFORTS
AND FUNDING INTO THEM BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT WORTHY AND I WAS
REALLY STRUCK DURING OUR
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
SIMILARITIES- HOW INTRIGUING
THEY ARE- BETWEEN YOUR STORY
AND THAT THE TREATMENT OF THESE
YOUNG FOLKS AND PROBABLY THAT
PERSPECTIVE IS SOMETHING THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT AND WHAT WE
NEED TO HAVE- AS COMMISSIONERS-
OVER DJ J. SO I WAS JUST
WONDERING IF MAYBE. YOU KNOW IF
I WAS READING TO WENT TOO MUCH
INTO IT OR IF NOT IF YOU COULD
SORT OF SPEAK TO THIS. I
APPRECIATE THAT- THAT I BROUGHT
MY MOTHER INTO A FOR A REASON
BECAUSE AFTER MY PARENTS
DIVORCED MY MOTHER RAISED TO
THREE THREE DAUGHTERS ON HER
OWN PRIMARILY. AND ALSO WORKED
TWO JOBS AND I SHARE WITH YOU.
SHE SHE WAS ABLE TO GET HER
BLUFF AND EARLY WHEN SHE SAID
THE ONLY BE A POLICY MEANT
THAT- SHE WAS AT WORK. AND IN I
KNOW WHAT IT IS TO COME UP YOU
KNOW- BASICALLY HAVING. A
SITUATION WHERE YOUR MOTHER CAN
ALWAYS PROVIDE THE THINGS THAT
YOU FEEL YOU NEED OR TO BE ON
THE IN CROWD WITH KIDS WHO HAVE
MORE. AND I KNOW WHAT IT IS TO
HAVE A FREE LUNCH- ALL THE WAY
THROUGH MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH
SCHOOL- INTO- I WAS ABLE TO GO
TO WORK AT FOURTEEN AND A HALF.
AT THE CEDAR PROGRAM MAKING TEN
DOLLARS NO EXCUSE ME TWO
DOLLARS AND TEN CENTS AN HOUR-
THAT'S MY JOURNEY MY BEGINNING
OF MY CAREER- BUT- I KNOW IT IS
TO BE TOLD BY COUNCILLOR. THAT
YOU WILL GO TO COLLEGE BECAUSE
YOUR FAMILY CAN'T AFFORD IT IN
YOU DON'T NEED TO GO YOU DON'T
NEED TO TAKE ALGEBRA TWO.
BECAUSE WHAT I'M GOING TO
COLLEGE ANYWAY TAKE HOME AT. IN
THE KNOW WHAT IT IS TO GROW UP
IN A SITUATION WHERE YOU KNOW
PEOPLE ALWAYS WANT TO THINK
LESS OF YOU BECAUSE OF HOW YOU
LOOK OR WHAT THE BACKGROUND YOU
COME FROM. THEY DON'T TAKING
CONSIDERATION WHAT'S BEEN
WARNING TO YOU THAT YOU CAN
ACHIEVE ANYTHING AND YOU'RE
JUST AS GOOD AS ANYONE ELSE AND
THAT YOUR LIFE. WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IF YOU STAY THE
COURSE AND SO I'M I USED THOSE.
PERSONAL STRUGGLE SO PERSONNEL.
THAT MY MOTHER SOLD. GAVE TO US.
IN KNOW SOME OF THE JUMP. ARE
GOING THROUGH. THEY'RE NOT HAVE
A FATHER IN THE HOME AND THE
FILL LIGHT WHY CAN YOU HAVE A
DIFFERENT FAMILY AND NOT BE
WITH OUR FAMILY. AND WHAT THAT
CAN DO TO YOU IF YOU DON'T HAVE
A STRONG. YOU KNOW. PARENTS WHO
CAN WALK YOU THROUGH IT AND YOU
STILL. HAVE SOME DOUBTS ABOUT
YOURSELF. AND SO CONSEQUENTLY.
YOU KNOW I MERRY EARLY- AT
NINETEEN. IN PART OF THAT WAS
BECAUSE I FELT SAFE. AB I FELT
LIKE I COULD BE I COULD BE SAFE
WITH HIM. AND WE HAVE. RAISED A
FAMILY AND WE HAVE THREE
WONDERFUL SONS WHO BRING US ALL
KIND OF JOY BUT IT HAS BEEN A
ROAD THAT HASN'T BEEN EASY AND
I'LL JUST SHARE THIS LAST PIECE
INSTANCE DOCTOR TO BACK TO YOU.
IS WHEN I WENT INTO THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT I HAVE THE AUDACITY
TO BELIEVE. THAT BECAUSE I WENT
THROUGH THE ACADEMY AND WORE
THAT BLUE UNIFORMS AND A HARD
FOR SERVICE AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTED. AND IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR IT JUST WASN'T THE
CASE. AND IT WAS TOUGH. BUT AS
MY MOM SAID WHAT DOESN'T KILL
YOU WILL MAKE YOU STRONGER AND
I'M STRONGER FOR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR
I'M GONNA TURN TO SENATOR
GROWTH NOW. THANK YOU M. MR FOR
BEING HERE TODAY WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE IT. YOUR STORY IS
VERY COMPELLING I TOO WAS
RAISED BY A SINGLE MOM- EIGHT
FREE LUNCHES SO YOUR STORIES
VERY COMPELLING- MY MOM WAS ONE
OF THE FIRST NINE ONE ONE
OPERATORS IN THE ARBOR POLICE
DEPARTMENT- SO. I JUST I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT- AND I'LL KEEP
MY COMMENTS SHORT I DON'T HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR YOU I READ
YOUR BIO- I'VE READ A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT YOU. AND I
WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT AND I
REALLY FEEL LIKE IT BUT YOUR
LIFE TESTIMONY THE TRAINING
THAT YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH. THE
JOBS THAT YOU HAVE HELD AT THE
DEGREES THAT YOU HAVE GOTTEN.
WILL PUT YOU IN A PERFECT
POSITION FOR THIS LEGACY
POSITION WHERE YOU CAN INVEST
IN THE NEXT GENERATION TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THEY HAVE EVERY
AFFORDED OPPORTUNITY POSSIBLE
TO BE PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY. AND I DO- AND THAT
THAT CAN LIVE OUT LIFE THAT
THEY'RE YOU KNOW CALL TO DO. I
DO WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON SENATOR
BATES IS COMMENTS ABOUT THAT
THE TRACKING OR THAT THE DATA
INFORMATION. I THINK THAT'S
REALLY GOOD IN A COUPLE OF
WAYS- ONE WE CAN CELEBRATE THE
SUCCESSES IN PROVIDING COURAGE
MEANT TO OTHERS GOING THROUGH.
A YOUTH AUTHORITY OR YOU'VE
PROGRAMS INTO IF YOU FIND- A
YOUNG PERSON THAT SEEMS TO
DEVIATE BACK AWAY FROM THE PAST
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO GET BACK ON
THAT. PATH AGAIN AND TO BE ALL
THAT THEIR- CALL TO BE- IN THIS
LIFE- SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HAVING THE COURAGE AND- THE
WILLINGNESS TO- TAKE ON THIS
POSITION AND I WISH YOU. THE
VERY BEST THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR. SENATOR
LAYERED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MAN PROTON N. BOB WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE- I ENJOYED OUR
CONVERSATION- I KNOWTHERE WERE
TIMES THAT WERE DIFFICULT BOB
HOPE BUT IT WAS REALLY HELPFUL.
IN THE IS CENTER CALM WALKER
WENT DOWN A COUPLE OF THE ROADS
THAT- THAT I WANTED TO GO DOWN
BUT LET ME MAY BE AT A POINT TO
A COUPLE OF THOSE AND ONE IS IT
WAS VERY INTERESTING TO ME THAT
WHEN WE TALKED. ABOUT WHAT IT
WAS LIKE TO GO ON THE POLICE
FORCE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
YOU ALSO TALKED ABOUT. BEING
PROMOTED. AND HAVING PEOPLE
TELL YOU THAT. THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THEY DIDN'T THINK THEY HAD TO
PAY ATTENTION TO YOU. COULD YOU
TALK ABOUT THAT FOR A SECOND.
YES WHEN I SHARE WITH YOU IS
WHEN I WAS PROMOTED TO
SERGEANT- A COUPLE OF THE MALE
OFFICERS FELT THAT THEY DID NOT
HAVE TO FOLLOW DIRECTION- IN
STARKVILLE SERGEANTS IN
PARTICULAR JUST TO PUT SOME
CONTEXT TO IT. ARE IN CHARGE OF
LIEUTENANTS RUN THE DAY TO DAY
THEY RUN YOU KNOW THE BUDGET
AND SO FORTH BUT THE SERGEANTS
REALLY OVERSEE THE OFFICERS
THEY ARE CRITICAL COMPONENTS.
OF HOLDING OFFICERS ACCOUNTABLE
DEALING WITH COMPLAINTS AND
ENSURING THAT THE WORK GETS
DONE SO TO HAVE THESE- OFFICERS
ALLEN'S MY ALREADY AND- WHEN
THEY WANTED TO HAVE AN ARREST
APPROVAL REPORT. THEY BASICALLY
PUSHED BACK ON ME- I HAD TO
MAKE A REAL DECISION THERE IN
IT WAS IN MY TRYING TO BE LIGHT
OR MIKE GOING TO BE RESPECTED
AND I CHOSE TO GO WITH RESPECT.
AND SO- ARM SIGNS ALSO HAVE THE
ABILITY TO. FILE A COMPLAINT
AND TO STAFF AND I AGAINST
OFFICER FRAN SUPPORT NATION IT
ONLY TOOK WALKS. AND I'VE I'VE
ENDED UP BEING LIKE BECAUSE I'M
FAIR BUT I WAS DEFINITELY GOING
FOR RESPECT AND I DID EARN.
THANK YOU. ARE BECAUSE I THINK
SOMETIMES GIVEN THE NEXT THING
I'M GOING TO ASK ABOUT IT'S
HARD TO IMAGINE. WHAT WAS GOING
ON IN A TIME AND A PLACE THAT
THAT MIGHT BE DIFFERENT. WE
ALSO TALKED OF. ABOUT THE
SITUATION THAT YOU HAD WITH.
ARE YOUR PATROL PARTNER WHEN
YOU WERE- OUR FIRST ON THE
FORCE. AND THE FACT THAT HE IS
IN ESSENCE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
HIV AND- ARE. YOU WERE ACTUALLY
GIVEN THE OPTION TO TRANSFER
AWAY FROM HIM BECAUSE OF THAT
GROUP WHICH- I. WAS TOUCHING
COULD YOU TALK ABOUT THAT A
LITTLE LIKE WHAT THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE WAS WHAT THE
SITUATION WAS AND SOME OF THE
DECISIONS YOU HAVE TO WORK
THROUGH AND THAT. YES IT IS- IT
WAS A TOUGH TIME AND I ALWAYS
SAY THAT PEOPLE DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND PEOPLE ARE AFRAID-
HIV AND AIDS IT WAS- SOMETHING
THAT SWOOPED DOWN ON A NUMBER
OF. PEOPLE IN COMMUNITIES AND
FAMILIES. AND SO CONSEQUENTLY
WHAT ENDED UP HAPPENING WAS
THAT- MY COULD POLICE PARTNER
SHARE WITH ME BECAUSE YOU'VE
BEEN TAKING SOME TIME ALL. IF
WE DON'T TAKE A LOT OF TIME OFF
HERE. AND ROUGHLY AND ROUGHLY
WHEN WAS THIS WHAT WHAT ARE WE
TALKING NINETEEN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE AFTER THANK YOU
NINETEEN NINETY ONE AND HE
SHARED WITH ME THAT HE HAD-
BEEN DIAGNOSED HIV. ARM AND
THAT HE WAS HAVING SOME
DIFFICULTIES BUT HE WAS GOING
TO THE DOCTOR TAKING MEDICATION
BUT HAD TO BE ON A REAL
REGIMENTED DIET SO WE WERE
ACTUALLY AT TRANSFERRED FROM
CONTROL AND HAVE BEEN WITHIN
THE TWO MONTHS OF ONE ANOTHER.
BEEN PUT IN- WHAT'S CALLED OUT
I A BACKGROUND INVESTIGATIONS
INTERNAL AFFAIRS SO WE WERE
WORKING ON BACKGROUNDS FOR
DISPATCHERS AND OFFICERS AND
SELF SUPPORT SO WE WERE IN A
OFFICE ENVIRONMENT BUT WHEN
SEVERAL WEEKS STOP INTO THAT
WITH MY HE SHARED WITH THE
SERGEANT- THE SERGEANTS SHARE.
PULLED ME INTO THE OFFICE AND
BASICALLY- SAID THAT I DIDN'T
HAVE TO WORK WITH HIM BECAUSE
HE DIDN'T WANT TO PUT THE
APPARATUS AND THAT- YOU KNOW I
HAD A CHOICE. IN YOU KNOW. I
WILL. I WAS TAKEN ABACK.
BECAUSE I JUST DID UNDERSTAND
HOW I WOULD HAVE BEEN SOME. WHO
IS NOT ONLY MY FRIENDS AND
COLLEAGUE BUT WITHIN A- TOUGH
TIME OF HIS LIFE. AND SO EDDIE
AND I TALK ABOUT IT YES MY
HUSBAND HERE. BUT I HAD ALREADY
REALLY MADE UP MY MIND- THAT
THERE WAS NO THERE WAS NOTHING
THAT WOULD HAVE ME TO ABANDON
YEAH. IN OUT OF IGNORANCE. SOME
PEOPLE SEND US ON THE PEOPLE WE
WERE GOING TO HAVE LUNCH WITH
YOU HAVE LUNCH WITH ANYMORE
SOME OF THE PEOPLE THAT WE
WOULD HANG OUT WITH FOR BEER
AFTER WORK WE DIDN'T DO THAT
ANYMORE. NOT. WE JUST DIDN'T
GET INVITED. AND THAT WAS A
TOUGH TIME I I WILL TELL YOU
THAT WHEN I MET HIS PARTNER-
WILL BRING LUNCH SOMETIMES AND
I SING CAN BE SO MUCH TO. BUT
WHEN I MET AS IT REALLY GAVE ME
A CLEAR INSIGHT TO LOVE. THAT
WAS GENUINE CARE AND WHEN.
DAVID ULTIMATELY WITHIN THE
HOSPITAL FOR AGE AND HE WAS
EXTREMELY L. ARM. I MET HIS
FAMILY WHO HAD NOT INITIALLY
ACCEPTED THEIR RELATIONSHIP AND
THEY ARE ALL CAME TO UNDERSTAND
JUST WHAT I DID IS THAT.
COMMITMENT AND LOVE DOES NOT
HAVE ANY BOUNDARIES ON. SAME
SEX OR OR OR YOU KNOW HAVE SEX
IT'S ABOUT LEADING SOME AND IT
WAS SOME LIFE CHANGING AND I'LL
NEVER WASTE- AND I SHARE WITH
YOU I I'VE ALWAYS HAD PEOPLE OF
VARIOUS BACKGROUNDS AROUND ME
BUT THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I
EVERSAW RELATIONSHIP A
RELATIONSHIP. AND- I AM
GRATEFUL FOR THAT THEY ALLOWED
ME TO ARM SHARE IN THAT VERY
VERY TOUGH TIME BECAUSE IT WAS.
IT NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THAT- I SAW STRAPPING
STRONG. 101% POLICE OFFICER GO
DOWN TO SKIN AND BONES. IT WAS
THAT. THANK YOU FOR FROM.
TALKING ABOUT THAT- AND I THINK
IT IT GETS TO ANOTHER THING
THAT SENATOR COM ORDER WAS
TALKING TO YOU ABOUT SIR YOU
YOU FAST FORWARD AND YOU GO TO
BIOLA UNIVERSITY THE T. H. A.
AND YOU SAID WHY YOUR GOING
WHAT WAS IMPORTANT TO DO. BUT
THEN THEY WANTED TO MAKE YOU
SIGN SOMETHING OR MULTIPLE
THINGS TO GO IN. THAT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN IN CONFLICT WITH WHAT
YOU JUST SAID. HOW DO YOU
HANDLE LEFT. YOU KNOW THEY SAID
BEFORE I WAS RECRUITED- AND
IT'S NICE TO BE NEEDED NEXT TO
BE SOUGHT OUT- AND SO THERE IS
AND I SHARE WITH YOU BEFORE AN
OVERALL CONTRACT OF YOU KNOW
THESE ARE POLICIES I SIGNED A
CONTRACT WHEN I WENT TO
UNIVERSITY OF PHOENIX I WENT TO
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT. BUT WHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN HAVE BECOME
MORE SOMEONE'S MADE AN ISSUE-
IS THE CONTRACT WHICH HAS OVER
THIRTY VARIOUS QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHO YOU ARE JUST LIKE WHEN I
WHEN I FILLED OUT FOR YOU ALL
THESE VARIOUS QUESTIONS. AND
THREE OF THEM OF THE THIRTY
PLUS YOU KNOW I PUT WERE
REGARDING ABORTION AND AME SEX
AND I THINK IT WAS THERE WITH
YOU ONE ABOUT- US DIMSDALE IN
YOU KNOW- I'M SORRY RESEARCH.
RESEARCH YES THANK YOU. AND YOU
KNOW IN THE I SAID EXACTLY IN
THE THREE I SAID EXACTLY WHAT I
SAID TO SENATOR- HOWEVER IS
THAT. MY TEACHING IS THAT THE
BIBLE IS ABOUT LOVE IT'S ABOUT
NOT JUDGING AND IT'S ABOUT
TAKING PEOPLE AS THEY COME AND
LET GOD DO THE REST OF THE WORK
THAT I WAS THERE NOT TO TEACH
THEOLOGY I WAS THERE TO TEACH
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND I WOULD
NOT. EVEN CONSIDER TRYING TO
TEACH THEOLOGY AND WHEN I GAVE
IT BACK TO THE DEAN AND SHE
LOOKED AT IT SHE SAYS THAT'S
WHY YOU'RE HERE TEACH CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. SO YOU I'M ABOUT YOU
DIDN'T ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE ON THOSE SUBJECTS YOU
JUST MENTION. I WAS NOT I WAS
NOT REQUIRED TO. THANK YOU AND
THEN THERE'S- THERE'S ONE OTHER
ISSUE THAT HAS BEEN RAISED R.
IN THE COURSE OF THIS AND
INVOLVES. BOB POLICE SHOOTING
OF A YOUNG UNARMED- AFRICAN
AMERICAN MAN WHILE YOU WERE.
THE PUBLIC INFORMATION OFFICER
OF THE POLICE DEPARTMENT AND I
WONDERED IF YOU WOULD DESCRIBE
BRIEFLY WHAT THE SITUATION IS.
AND WHETHER YOU MADE ANY
COMMENTS THAT WERE PERSONAL THE
COMMENTS YOU MADE A DURING THE
COURSE OF THAT SITUATION. THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THAT YOU KNOW-
AND YOU'RE RIGHT THERE WAS
AWESOME ALL SHOOTING- ABOUT ONE
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING I WAS
NOTIFIED CLOSE TO TWO THIRTY
THREE AM. NOW THAT THE CHIEF
WANTED ME TO OUR RESPONSE AND
WHICH I DID AND- DURING THAT
INVESTIGATION IT WAS BELIEVED
THAT TAT YOUNG HAT GUNMEN HAD
WELL HE DID THE ROBBERY BUT
BELIEVE HE HAD A GUN. AND
TURNED OUT THAT THE SO CALLED
VICTIM ENDED UP LYING TO GET
THE POLICE THERE EARLIER HE DID
END UP LOSING ON HIS LIFE WHEN
HE ENCOUNTERED THE OFFICERS
TRAGIC. HEARTFELT SITUATION BUT
I WAS THERE AS THE PUBLIC
INFORMATION OFFICER IT. I DON'T
I REPORT WHAT. TWO AND THAT SHE-
HAVE PUT OUT AND IT SAYS RENTAL
STATUS AND CONTACT LIEUTENANT
RIDDLE IF YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS BUT I
DON'T GET TO SPEAK FROM ANY
PERSONAL BASE. BY FRANKLY I'M
NOT PART OF THE INVESTIGATION
TEAM. AND SO WHEN I READ THAT I
HAD MADE OR HAD DONE SOME
INVESTIGATION AND HAD MADE SOME
SOME STATEMENTS UNLIKE THIS
PERSON DIDN'T. BOTHER TO ASK ME
OR TO BOTHER TO. FIND OUT WHAT
THE PROCESS IS WHEN YOU HAVE A
ON P. I. O. AND SO- IT COULD BE
FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH BUT I
HAVE IS NOT THE FIRST TIME. YOU
KNOW I GAVE SOMEONE A BUSINESS
CAR MANY YEARS AGO AND SAID IF
YOU WANT TO MAKE A COMPLAINT
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED PLEASE GIVE
ME A CALL AND I GOT TWO ONE TWO
NINETY NINE SO. HEY I DIDN'T SO
THE PERSON THAT I WOULD TAKE
THEIR COMPLAINT PUT THOSE IN A
WAY THAT PART OF THE JOB AND SO
ON IT WAS MISREPORTED HE SAID
TO PUT A SPECIFIC POINT ON AT.
I IT WAS YOU THE PUB AND-
OFFICER MOVING OUT OTHER
PEOPLE'S COMMENTS THEY WERE NOT
YOUR COMMENTS IS THAT COUNCIL.
MAY I DON'T HAVE I DON'T HAVE
COMMENTS IN THOSE SITUATIONS.
OKAY WELL- D. E. B. I
APPRECIATE YOU BOB BEING
WILLING TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS I KNOW THEY WERE
DIFFICULT AND- I KNOW WITH- YOU
MIGHT NOT THINK IT'S FAIR BUT I
JUST THINK WHEN THOSE ISSUES
ARE RAISED WE HAVE TO. ASK THEM
AND GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT AND
I FEEL LIKE WE JUST DID SO I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALSO I APPRECIATE
YOU. SENATOR THANK YOU HI
DOCTORAL I WANNA COME IN ON TWO
THINGS ONE- AN UNRELATED ITEM
BUT ONE THAT I'M PARTICULARLY-
IMPORTANT TO ME SB SIX TWENTY
FIVE WHICH JUST HAPPENED TO BE
MY BILL. ESTABLISHED I KNOW
SHOCKING AND THEN- THIS IS
REESTABLISHED WHAT'S CALLED AN
HONORABLE DISCHARGE PROGRAM FOR
JUVENILE OFFENDERS. THAT
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED
SUPERVISION AFTER BEING UNDER
STATE CUSTODY AND THE ABILITY
TO EARN AN HONORABLE DISCHARGE
RECOGNIZES. THE PROGRESS THAT A
YOUNG PERSON IS MADE AFTER
LEAVING DJJ AND REMOVES
BARRIERS TO CERTAIN
OCCUPATIONAL LICENSES DUE TO
THEIR CRIMINAL BACKGROUND. A
YOUTH WHO WAS UNABLE TO EARN AN
HONORABLE DISCHARGE MAY FACE
BARRIERS TO OBTAINING A LICENSE
TO BECOME MAYBE A BARBER OR
COSMETOLOGIST THE CONTRACTOR
CORRECTIONS OFFICER ECCENTRIC.
IN A WARD OF AN HONORABLE
DISCHARGE WILL DEMONSTRATE
REHABILITATION TO FUTURE
EMPLOYERS UNFORTUNATELY OR
WE'RE SEEING THAT DJJ REPORTS
THAT THEY RECEIVED RELATIVELY
FULL FEW COMPLETE APPLICATIONS
FOR HONORABLE DISCHARGE- AND
THEY REVIEWED FOR APPLICATIONS
LAST YEAR AND ALL FOUR WERE
GRANTED. HAVE YOU DO YOU HAVE
YOU YOURSELF HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO CONDUCT AN HONORABLE
DISCHARGE HEARING AND WHY DO
YOU THINK THE DJJ DOESN'T
RECEIVE MORE APPLICATIONS IS.
THE PROGRAM SOMETHING YOU
DISCUSS WITH YOUTH ARE
ENCOURAGED TO PURSUE ANY
THOUGHTS ON. HOW TO HAVE YOUNG
PEOPLE TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT
PROGRAM. SO THERE'S A LOT IN
THERE BUT YES I HAVE SORRY OKAY
THAT'S OKAY YES AND YES AND YES
EVERY IN EVERY DISCHARGED
CONSIDERATION I'LL GO BACK TO
THEIR- ANNUAL REVIEWS THEY ARE
TOLD ABOUT THE HONORABLE
DISCHARGE AND HOW TO GO ABOUT
IT. AND THEY ARE GIVEN- FORM
WHICH NOW YOU CAN DOWNLOAD ON
YOUR COMPUTER OF THE THAT- WITH
A Q. R. CODES BUT HOW TO GO
ABOUT GETTING AN HONORABLE
DISCHARGE AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
IT TO THEIR FUTURE LIFE AND SO
THEY GET THAT NOT ONLY DURING
THE ANNUAL BUT AT THE
DESTRUCTION INSPIRATION
HEARINGS AND IS DOCUMENTED ON
THEIR ON OUR BOARD ORDERS. AND
THE- PROBATION OFFICERS THREES
ALWAYS ENSURE THAT THEY ARE ARE
FOLLOWED UP ON AND HAVE THE
ACCURATE INFORMATION I HAVE
PERSONALLY DONE A NUMBER OF
HONORABLE DISCHARGES SINCE I'VE
BEEN HERE AND I'LL TELL YOU
IT'S A WONDERFUL FEELING TO BE
ABLE TO SAY YES. OUR MOTION IS
TO APPROVE AND TO CONCUR AND
ALLOW THAT YOUNG PERSON TO HAVE
IT YOU JUST HAVE TO GO ALL IS
LIKE IF. HELLO AND WE DON'T GET
TO THE COURTHOUSE YOU KNOW MAKE
SURE THAT YOU TAKE THE FORM
WITH YOU AND LET THE JUDGE KNOW
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN APPROVED AT
FOR THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
OR SINCE YOU'VE BEEN RELEASED
AND A LOT OF TIMES IT'S LONGER
THAN THAT THAT YOU HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY REINTEGRATED INTO
THE COMMUNITY AND I. OUR LAST
NIGHT MYSELF ON AGAIN I DON'T
KNOW WHAT YOUR BILL BUT KUDOS
TO YOU. OKAY YOU I THOUGHT ALL
ABOUT THE PRODUCT IS WHAT THIS
WONDERFUL IS ONE AFTER. I KNOW
PEOPLE PERSONALLY AND JUST
COMPLETELY. IN MY OWN FAMILY
THAT HAVE USE THAT ARE THAT
HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
NOW THE Y. MORE PEOPLE DOING IT
I HAVE ALL THE YOU'RE- I THAT
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT THEY
KNOW. I SOMETIMES LIFE. ALL
WEEK WEEK THAT THAT STAFF.
CONTINUOUSLY ASK THEM IT IS NOT
DIFFICULT YOU KNOW JUST GET A-
A PROBATION REPORT I ENSURE
THAT THE RIGHT IS A LITTLE BIO
ON WHAT YOU'RE DOING NOW IF YOU
WANT TO HAVE SOMEONE COME AND
SPEAK FOR YOU IN SUPPORT. LIKE
A R. C. OR SOME OTHER MENTOR
SHIP PROGRAM THAT YOU'RE
INVOLVED IN AND THEN WE JUST
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH. THANK
YOU AND I SHOULD BE A
STRAIGHTFORWARD HERE AND SAY
THAT I RE ESTABLISH THE PROGRAM
SOMEONE ELSE ACTUALLY DID THE
BILL TO GET IT DONE BUT IT IT
WENT THE WAY SIDE SO I WANT TO
TAKE CREDIT FROM. SOMEONE
PREVIOUSLY WHO WHO REALLY
DESERVED IT. YOU KNOW I THINK I
KNOW THE ANSWER TO THIS BUT-
I'M GOING TO ASK BASED ON SOME
OF THE COMMENTS YOU MADE ABOUT
ACCEPTANCE AND- YOU KNOW THE
LESSONS YOU LEARNED FROM YOUR
MOTHER I LEARN THE SAME LESSONS
FOR MY MOTHER. I GREW UP IN THE
SOUTH AS WELL AND- YOU KNOW
IT'S A DIFFERENT APPROACH ON
LIFE ARE. THE TEMPLE WHERE YOU
GROW UP AND MY MOTHER WAS ONE
OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT ARE.
REALLY LOVED EVERYONE SHE
DIDN'T REALLY CARE WHAT THEIR
STORY WAS IT WASN'T RELEVANT TO
HER SHE WAS A WOMAN OF FAITH
ALSO- SO I REALLY APPRECIATED
YOUR APPROACH IN YOUR COMMENTS
ON THAT- BUT IN OTHER UP
APPOINTMENTS WHERE WE'VE TALKED
TO- PARTICULARLY MEMBERS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT CDC ARCSEC TRASH.
I'VE ASK- AND ALSO- OTHER A
PROBATION ADULT PROBATION-
ABOUT IT IF YOU COME IN CONTACT
WITH A MEMBER OF THE LGBT
COMMUNITY SINCE OBVIOUSLY
PEOPLE FELT COMPELLED TO BRING
THAT UP IS AN ISSUE WHEN WE GOT
COMMENTS AND LETTERS- IT YOU
DON'T ALWAYS KNOW SO I'M NOT
GOING TO ASSUME. THAT PEOPLE
DISCLOSE THAT TO YOU YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE DISCLOSED THAT TO
YOU. BUT IN YOUR EXPERIENCE
HAVE YOU COME ACROSS THE US SO
MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ. Q.
COMMUNITY THAT YOU'VE BEEN ABLE
TO ADVISE AND COUNSEL AND I
WOULD ASSUME BASED ON MY VERY
SAID THAT YOU TREAT THEM. I
EQUITY AND GIVE THE SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED AND- JUST YOU
WANT TO COMMENT IF YOU'VE FELT
LIKE YOU'VE COME ACROSS SOME.
YOUNG FOLKS. WELL THE ANSWER
WILL BE ABSOLUTELY- SINCE I'VE
BARED MY SOUL HERE TODAY. YES.
YOU YOU CERTAINLY HAVE. YEAH
YES IN I MIGHT MY MEANT HE WAS
NOW MY GOD DAUGHTER- I MET HER
WHEN SHE WAS FOURTEEN. AND
TOUGH TOUGH STORY TO HELP HER I
HAD TO WAIT MIDDLE SCHOOL AND-
IT JUST CONTINUED FROM THERE.
THE REASON I BRING HER UP IN
PARTICULAR IS BECAUSE- WHEN SHE
WAS SEVENTEEN SHE HAD- MY GOD
SON YOU KNOW LOW CONNOR- AND-
IT WASN'T A GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH HER BOYFRIEND WHATEVER
HAPPENED IT DIDN'T IT DIDN'T
WORK OUT. BUT ABOUT THREE YEARS
AGO SHE SHE CAME TO ME AND
SHARE THAT- SHE WAS IN A
RELATIONSHIP- AND THAT HER
FATHER AND FAMILY WERE
COMPLETELY AGAINST THEM I WAS
KIND OF TAKEN ABACK I DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT SHE FRIDAY WOULD BE.
ABOUT MY GOD WHAT IS HE LIKE A
MAJOR DRUG DEALERS SOMETHING I
DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE'S TALKING
ABOUT AND THEN SHE SAID NO IT'S
A IT'S ANOTHER GIRL. AND SHE
WAS IN TEARS I MEAN. IT
HEARTFELT TEARS AND IT BROKE MY
HEART BECAUSE SHE IS ONE OF THE
SWEETEST YOUNG WOMEN. THAT YOU
COULD EVER WANT TO MEET AND I
LOVE HER AND SHE SAID. ARE YOU
GONNA YOU KNOW AMANDA ME BACK
IN MY FAMILY ROOM. THANK. YOU
ALABAMA ME TO. I DON'T DO THAT
BY SEN LEILA. THANK YOU KNOW. I
DON'T I DON'T SUBSCRIBE TO THAT
AND I WANT TO BE TREATED A
CERTAIN WAY AND THEY'RE FINE
OBLIGATED TO TREAT OTHERS THAT
WAY. THANK YOU DOCTOR REAL YOU
KNOW OUR I WOULD JUST SAY MY
PARENTS NEVER BANDED ME EITHER
I'M PRETTY SURE THEY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND- BUT THEY THEY
DIDN'T ABANDON THEIR CHILD AND
I AM FOREVER GRATEFUL FOR THAT-
IN THE REASON I ASKED THAT
QUESTION IS BECAUSE WE HAVE
TALKED TO OTHER- WHEN WE WERE
WORKING ON SOME OF THE CD ARE-
CDC. OF APPOINTMENTS AND
DEALING WITH- MEMBERS OF THE
TRANS GENDER NON BINARY
COMMUNITY WE HAD TO DO SOME
EDUCATION- IN THE PRISON SYSTEM
AND REQUIRE AND ASK THEM TO DO
SOME TRAINING. AND SO IT'S NOT
AN UNCOMMON QUESTION TO ASK AND
I THINK IT'S A VERY RELEVANT
ONE AND I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
YOUR- SHARON- SOME PRETTY
PERSONAL- EXAMPLES WITH US THAT
IS A- CLEARLY BEYOND. WHAT
WOULD BE EXPECTED IN AN
APPOINTMENT SO I DO APPRECIATE
YOU TAKING THE TIME TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU. YEAH ABSOLUTELY- IF
NO OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
OR MY COLLEAGUE COLLEAGUES-
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. AND WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WHO WE'RE GONNA START
WITH IN SUPPORT. AND I AM GOING
TO ASK THIS AS WE GO TO MEMBERS
AND SUPPORT AND IN OPPOSITION.
OUT WE DO HAVE A LONG AGENDA
AND I HAVE A CUSTOM AND
PRACTICE AND TRADITION IN THIS
COMMITTEE. OF LETTING PEOPLE
TALK AT LENGTH AS MY COLLEAGUES
KNOW. BUT I AM PROBABLY GONNA
ASK- AFTER THE FIRST OR SECOND
PERSON THAT YOU GIVE YOUR- NAME
AND ORGANIZATION THAT YOU MIGHT
BE WITH AND YOUR- SUPPORT. I
APPRECIATE- PEOPLE WANTING TO
GIVE A LOT OF COMMENTARY BUT WE
HAVE. A NUMBER OF OTHER
APPOINTMENTS AND I WANT TO BE
RESPECTFUL TO PEOPLE WAITING IN
THE QUEUE BUT I WANNA MAKE SURE
YOU GET TO REGISTER YOUR
SUPPORT. AND YOUR OPPOSITION
SO- I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT OUT
THERE FIRST- WE ARE GOING TO
START RIGHT HERE IN ROOM.
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT. AND I ACTUALLY I'M NOT
SEEING ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
HERE I'M GOING TO GO TO- STILL
IN THE YES I'M SORRY ACTUALLY
HAVE TWO PEOPLE THAT WAS THERE
IN SUPPORT I DON'T KNOW IF THEY
KNOW HOW TO GET A HANDLE. ON IT
IT- IF THEY WERE HERE IN
SUPPORT PUBLICLY- YOU KNOW IF
THERE ARE THEY IF THEY'RE ON
THE TELECONFERENCE WILL LOVE
WILL LOVE GET TO THEM IN JUST A
MINUTE. HEY WE ARE ALLOWING
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN TO THE
DEGREE THAT IT IS POSSIBLE AND
SO IF PEOPLE SHOW UP IN PUBLIC
ARE WE DO HEAR THEM- IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. I'M NOT
SEEING ANYONE- FROM THE PUBLIC
WE DO HAVE ANOTHER ROOM AND
THAT IS ROOM ONE TWELVE OR WE
MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IF THEY WANT TO BE
HERE SO THAT WE CAN SOCIALLY
DISTANCE. APPROPRIATELY AND
FOLLOW THE HEALTH GUIDELINES I
AM LOOKING AT MY SCREEN WHICH
SHOWS ROOM ONE TWELVE. AND I
SEE NO ONE- APPROACHING THE
DYESS- THERE TO SPEAK SO I AM
NOW GOING TO GO WHICH IS
PROBABLY WHERE OF THE SUPPORT.
COMMENTS ARE TOO- A MODERATOR
ODD TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ON
THE TELECONFERENCE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO. TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT
AND- SO LET ME WELCOME THE
MODERATOR AND ASK OUR- FOR HER
TO HER OR HIM TO IDENTIFY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. WE'RE. WE'RE JUST
WE'RE JUST GONNA WAIT ON THE
MODERATOR TO JOIN US TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY ONLY TAKE A SECOND.
WELL IT'S GOING TO BE A MINUTE
I STAND CORRECTED THANK YOU.
WHILE UP WE ARE WAITING ON. THE
MODERATOR TO COME ON BOARD I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE DID GET A
COUPLE OF LETTERS. R. AS THE
COMMITTEE STARTED TODAY AND I
ASKED THE SECRETARY TO PASS
THOSE LETTERS OUT TO MY
COLLEAGUE SHOULD HAVE THOSE
LETTERS IN ADDITION TO WHAT WAS
ALREADY IN YOUR BACK UP- FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SOME
REFERENCED IN THE COMMENTS
ALREADY BUT IN OPPOSITION AND
SUPPORT WE HAVE. RECEIVED
LETTERS FROM BOTH SALAS WANNA
MAKE SURE FOR THE RECORD PEOPLE
KNOW THAT WE HAVE THOSE LETTERS.
I CAMERA SCREEN BETTER.
THE
OPERATOR ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR
ME I CAN HEAR YOU THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR FOR JOINING US
AND IF AT SOME POINT YOU CAN
TELL ME THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY AND THEN
PROCEED. THANK YOU. IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND THIS IS FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I HAVE THREE ZERO BE A
MOMENT FOR THE FIRST ONE. AND
MARK TWAIN FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RISKY THANK YOU GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS THE AMERICAN
DOLLARS- CHAIRMAN OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT APPROACH-
AND MEMBERS AT THIS TIME WHERE
VOICES OF BLACK LEADERS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE NEEDED MORE
THAN EVER I STRONGLY EXPRESSED
MY SUPPORT FOR THE NOMINATION
APPOINTMENT A DOCTOR BLOND HERE
MIDDLE TO THE JUVENILE PAROLE
BOARD OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SHE IS BOTH LIKED
AND RESPECTED BY MANY OF US
HERE AND I STRONGLY URGE AT THE
PARK OPERATE POINTS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MATAMATA
RAIDER NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
I'M THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU MIGHT BE MUTED LINE. THIRTY
NINE. WE'RE TRYING TWELFTH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLIND YOUR
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE
WE'LL GET THAT OKAY WE MAY WE
MAY PICK THIS PERSON UP BY
WE'VE HAD THIS HAPPEN BEFORE
PEOPLE CALL IN DIFFERENT LINES
SO BAD MODERATOR IF YOU TRAVEL
MORE TIME AND THEN WILL
PROCEED. ON WITH THE HEARING.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
IN A FEW MOMENTS I'M SURE- WE
WILL MOVE TO I HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE
FOR MANY OPPOSITION. SOL START
RIGHT HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE AND AGAIN I SEE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE ARE
IN PERSON. SO I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND LOOK AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE AGAIN JUST TO MAKE SURE
NO ONE IS THERE. I SEE NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO ON MANTA
MODERATOR I AM BACK WITH YOU
NOW. AND THIS IS FOR- MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION AND
AGAIN. LET ME REMIND YOU IT IS
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION OF
ANY REPRESENT AND YOUR POSITION
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN FOR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ACTORS
TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. MADAME
MODERATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH ARE
WE WILL GET BACK TO YOU IN OUR
NEXT APPOINTMENT SERIES SO- I'M
GONNA BRING IT BACK- GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO
SUPPORT IT IS SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. RECOGNIZE AND
AGAIN THAT WE DID RECEIVE SOME
LETTERS IN OPPOSITION BUT WE
ALSO HAD ALREADY BACK UP OF
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION LET ME BRING IT BACK
TO MY COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND-
FOR MOTION. I HAD FOR MOTION SO
I'M GONNA RECOGNIZE THE VICE
CHAIR- SENATOR BATES MADE A
MOTION. MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROWTH
HI- I KAMLAGER HI LONGER I
LAYERED FIVE BY FAITH ALL RIGHT
I ATKINS HIGH CONCISE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DOCTOR RIDDLE OUT
UNANIMOUS CONGRATULATIONS AND
THANK YOU FOR VERY MUCH THANK
YOU FOR THE TIME YOU SPENT WITH
US TODAY AND TO MISTER HUSBAND
WHO I FIRST NAME AYE DADDY
DADDY THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY
WE'RE YOU THANK YOU. OKAY I'M
GOING TO LOOK TO SEE IF WE NEED
TO TAKE A SHORT BREAK. YES WE
WILL TAKE UP A FIVE MINUTE
BREAK- WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH
YOU THANKS IN RECESS FOR FIVE
MINUTES.
MEETING BACK TO ORDER
I THANK YOU COLLEAGUES AND LET
ME THANK OUR NEXT APPOINTEE FOR
OUR INCREDIBLE PATIENCE. I
THINK WE HAVE A- SHAVON QATARI
WHO IS THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES ARE THIS QATARI
WELCOME AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE- WE WOULD
LIKE TO WELCOME YOU AND- ASK
YOU IF YOU WANT TO INTRODUCE
ANYONE THAT MIGHT BE WITH YOU-
MAKE OPENING COMMENTS AND THEN
WE'LL GO RIGHT TO COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE. SO
WELCOME. THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. I AM GRATEFUL FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD UPON
MY EXPERIENCE AND EXPAND MY
ABILITY TO SERVE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
I APPRECIATE THE TRUST THAT
GOVERNOR NEW SOME SECRETARY
GALLEY DIRECTOR JOHNSON HAVE
BEEN ASKING ME TO SERVE IN THIS
CAPACITY. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK MY MENTORS BOARD MEMBERS
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF ALONG THE
WAY. WHAT HELPED ME EVOLVE AS A
LEADER. FINALLY I AM BEYOND
GRATEFUL FOR MY TEAMS AT EDS
ASKED FOR THEIR ONGOING
ASSISTANCE TO TEACH ME WHAT I
NEED TO KNOW JUST SUPPORT THEIR
VITAL WORK. I WOULD LIKE TO
THINK MY HUSBAND'S JUNE KENOSHA
MY SON TAIYO AND MY FATHER
BROUGHT QATARI WHO ARE HERE IN
LIVE STREAM TODAY WITH ME. I
ALSO LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
REMEMBER MY MOTHER LORNA THE
PASSED AWAY LAST APRIL. AFTER
LIVING WITH THE HEALTH RELATED
DISABILITY FOR MOST OF HER
ADULT LIFE. MY EXPERIENCE
CARING FOR HER FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS. ABSOLUTELY INFORMED ME
AS A SOCIAL WORKER AND AS A
LEADER. IT CRYSTALLIZED MY
FOCUSED ON EVERY DOOR IS A
RIGHT GEORGE LOS IFFY. ON
LEVERAGING RESOURCES AND
PROGRAMS TO PROMOTE A WHOLE
PERSON APPROACH TO CARE. AND
BUILDING TEAMS WHO OPERATE WITH
EMPATHY AND COMPASSION FOR
THOSE THAT WE SERVE. I'VE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORKING
COUNTY SYSTEMS AND IN THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR ON A MULTITUDE
OF SOCIAL SERVICE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND HEALTH RELATED
ISSUES BEFORE COMING TO THE
STATE LAST JULY. MY INTENT IS
TO USE THIS EXPERIENCE TO
ASSIST DIRECTOR JOHNSON IN
MEETING THE DEPARTMENT'S GOALS
OF CONNECTING THE DOTS BETWEEN
PROGRAMS TO BUILD OUT THE
COMPREHENSIVE SYSTEMS OF CARE
FOR ADULTS CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. ALTHOUGH THE VAST
MAJORITY OF MY TIME SINCE
COMING TO CDSS HAS BEEN FOCUSED
ON THE PREVENTION AND
MITIGATION OF EFFORTS
SURROUNDING THE PANDEMIC I LOOK
FORWARD TO WHAT'S NEXT. AS WELL
AS THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE ENABLED THE
CREATION OF CRITICAL PROGRAMS
THAT SERVE CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE. THE DSS HAS A WIDE
ARRAY ARRAY OF PROGRAMS THAT WE
ADMINISTER. WITHIN THAT SCOPE I
HAVE FIVE. FIVE DIVISIONS UNDER
MY LEADERSHIP EACH WITH A
DIFFERENT SET OF GOALS AND
GROWTH OPPORTUNITIES. THE
COMMUNITY CARE LICENSING
DIVISION IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENSURING THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF CHILDREN AND ADULTS. WERE
OVERSIGHT OF CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS ADULT AND SENIOR
FACILITIES AND CHILDREN'S
RESIDENTIAL HOMES FOR FOSTER
YOU. OUR DISABILITY
DETERMINATION SERVICES DIVISION
DETERMINES ELIGIBILITY FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE APPLYING
FOR DISABILITY BENEFITS THROUGH
THE FEDERAL SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION. OUR DISASTER
SERVICES BRANCH IS THE MASTER
HEARING SHELTER LEAD FOR THE
STATE ENSURING THAT THROUGH
LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS COMMUNITIES
WHO ARE IN THE FACE OF DISASTER
ARE CARED FOR AND FED AND
SHELTERED. OUR STATE HEARINGS
DIVISION IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENSURING THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO
FEEL THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
AFFORDED THE BENEFITS THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO THE STATE SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS. HAVE A PLACE TO
APPEAL THIS DECISION AND LAST
BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST OUR
LEGAL DIVISION ENSURES THAT WE
ARE CROSSING OUR TEAS AND DOT
IN OUR EYES IN THE PROVISION OF
SERVICES AND OUR BUSINESS
PRACTICES THROUGHOUT THE
DEPARTMENT. DESPITE THE WIDE
VARIETY OF FUNCTIONS UNDER MY
UMBRELLA I HAVE SOME COMMON
GOALS THEY HOPE TO ACHIEVE.
THESE INCLUDE INCREASING IN OUR
ABILITY TO COLLECT AND MAKE
MEANINGFUL USE OF DATA TO
INFORM DECISION MAKING AND
FUTURE PLANNING. FRANKLIN
PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN CDSS
DIVISION AND EXTERNALLY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO BUILD MORE
EFFECTIVE SYSTEMS OF CARE FOR
THOSE WE SERVE. AND ENSURING
THAT OUR SERVICES ARE CREATED
AND EVALUATED OR IN EQUITY
LANDS PRIORITIZING THOSE WHO
NEED US MOST. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AND I AM
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
DIRECTOR LET ME START WITH OUR-
NEW MEMBER OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE SENATOR YOU READY GO.
KAMLAGER SURE THING MADAM CHAIR
WELL- I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR-
YOUR SERVICE FIRST OF ALL I
WANTED. TO SAY A SORRY FOR YOUR
LOSS I KNOW THE LOSS OF A
MOTHER- CAN BE DIFFICULT AND
I'M SURE IT WAS ESPECIALLY
TRYING LAST YEAR SO MY
CONDOLENCES TO YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY FOR THAT. YOU KNOW I ARE.
I'M JUST GONNA SAY FORGIVE ME
IN ADVANCE BECAUSE I HAVE A LOT
OF QUESTIONS- I WAS LOOKING
THROUGH THE BINDER AND OF
COURSE THE THING THAT WAS MOST
ARRESTING TO ME WERE THE
ARTICLES. ON- OUR CHILDREN WHO
WERE SENT TO OUT OF STATE
FACILITIES RUN BY THIS FOR
PROFIT- COMPANY. AND JUST
WANTED TO ASK YOU SOME
CLARIFYING QUESTIONS ON- SORT
OF YOUR ROLE ON THAT EXPERIENCE
ON NEXT STEPS- IF YOU DON'T
MIND SO I WAS WONDERING WHERE
DID YOU OVERSEE ALL OF THAT OR
WERE YOU APPOINTED AFTER. THIS
HAD HAPPENED. THANK YOU NO I
WAS ACTUALLY APPOINTED AFTER
THIS IT HAPPENS BUT CERTAINLY
ONE OF MY ROLES AND OVERSEEN
THE LICENSE ENOUGH FACILITIES
IT'S JUST CERTAINLY LOOK AT HOW
WE CAN IMPROVE GOING FORWARD
AND LESSONS LEARNED AND SO TO
THAT EXTENT- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I'VE REALLY BEEN WORKING
ON WITH MY TEAM AND COMMUNITY
CARE LICENSING AND IS LOOKING
AT THE WAY THAT WE- OVERSEE AND
MONITOR OUR PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
THAT THE LESSONS LEARNED THAT
THAT ARISE FROM THAT SO FOR
INSTANCE MAKING BETTER USE OF
DATA- AND ENSURING THAT WE'RE
MONITORING OUR FACILITIES
EFFECTIVELY- GOING FORWARD.
ABSOLUTELY I PRIORITY. FOR
MYSELF AND FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
AND SO HOW WOULD YOU THAT ON A
GO FOREIGN FORWARD BASIS IN
TERMS OF MONITORING I MEAN THIS
ISSUE AROUND CERTIFYING
FACILITIES AND RECERTIFYING
FACILITIES AND- INSPECTING THEM
IN. YEAH THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION SO ONE OF THE THINGS
JUST TAG GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND AS WE- IN TERMS OF
LICENSING WE LICENSE THE
FACILITIES WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OUTSIDE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THOSE FACILITIES
ARE ACTUALLY LICENSED BY OTHER
STATE BUT WE DO CERTIFY THOSE
FACILITIES SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT RELATIONSHIP THAT WE
HAVE. WITH OUT OF STATE
FACILITIES. LAST YEAR I IN THE
FACE OF SOME TRAGEDIES THAT
HAVE OCCURRED IN OUT OF STATE
FACILITIES THE DEPARTMENT MADE
A DECISION TO TAKE A LOOK AND
DO A COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF
ALL OF OUR OTHER STATE
FACILITIES. I'M WE DID THAT
THROUGH LOOKING AT A
COMBINATION OF COMPLAINT
INVESTIGATION FINDINGS SERIOUS
INCIDENT REPORT AND WERE YOU
LOOKING AT PROGRAMS STATEMENT
THAT HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED TO
ENSURE THAT FACILITIES
OPERATIONS WERE IN LINE WITH
WHAT THEY SAID THEY WERE GOING
TO DO. DURING THAT REVIEW
PROCESS WE DID MAKE A DECISION
TO DECERTIFY SIXTEEN OUT OF
STATE FACILITIES AND SO TO DATE
WE HAVE NO OUT OF STATE
FACILITIES. WE BROUGHT A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO YEARS
BACK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
COUNTIES AND PROVIDERS WITHIN
CALIFORNIA TO- TO THE STATE.
AND WE DID LEARN. A LOT OF
REALLY GOOD. REALLY HALF
SEVERAL MONTHS AND PROSPECT ONE
OF THE LESSONS IS. DATA AND
AROUND HOW WE- AND HOW WE TRACK
DATA WHEN IT COMES TO OUR OTHER
STATE FACILITIES. AND SO WHAT I
WILL SAY IS THAT WE WERE
LOOKING AT INCIDENTS THAT COME
UP WE WERE LOOKING AT THEM AND-
COUNTY PARTNERS FOR. A FLEETING
AGENCIES FOR LOOKING AT THE
INCIDENT HOWEVER WHAT WE DIDN'T
HAVE WITH THE GOOD SYSTEM IN
PLACE TO LOOK AT PATTERNS OF
INCIDENTS AND SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE BUILDING.
AND PUTTING IN PLACE. ADDITION
ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT IS THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE WITH.
CALIFORNIA AND ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE THE PLACEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU. SO THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE TO LEAVE THE
STATE SO THAT WE CAN SERVE THEM
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
MORE AND BETTER OVERSIGHT. AND
THEN OBVIOUSLY- THEY ARE MAYBE
NOT SO OBVIOUSLY BUT- ONE OF
THE THINGS WE ALWAYS HAVE TO
BALANCE THAT. IS THE BALANCE
BETWEEN PRESERVING PLACEMENT
AND ENSURING HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF THE YOUTH THAT WE SERVE. AND
SO. DURING THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM CHILD WELFARE ONE
OF THE THINGS WE STARTED TO
LOOK AT A LITTLE BIT CLOSER IN
THE STATE. IS NOT JUST WHETHER
OR NOT OUR LICENSED FACILITIES
WERE MEETING THEIR OBJECTIVES
BUT ALSO. NOT ONLY WHAT THEY
WERE DOING BUT HOW THEY WERE%
DOING THAT WERE THEY ACTUALLY
PROVIDING SERVICES THAT WORKS
FROM INFORMS IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE SPENDING THAT'S
OKAY THAT'S AN OVERLAY IN WHICH
WE AND LIFE WILL BE AND WILL BE
WORKING. OUT MORE CLOSELY WITH
OUR PARTNERS. IN THAT KIND OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES
DIVISION WHICH IS OVERSEEN BY
CHIEF DEPUTY JUDGE RIGHT NOW.
TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT WERE
OVERLAIN APOLOGY AND TROM
INFORMED FRAMEWORK IN THE LIFE
OF BEING OUT OF POSITION. SO
THOSE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
LESSONS LEARNED THAT I REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TO THE OPPORTUNITY
TO STRENGTHEN. THAT'S NOT
OVERSIGHT AND THAT CONTINUE OF
OPTIONS FOR YOU GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION SO
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO WERE THERE
DURING THIS. TIME WHO IN MY-
ESPECT OF KENDALL THIS KIND
BEHAVIOR THEY SO IN THE- I WILL
SAY THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
TRANSITIONS IN THE DEPARTMENT
HOWEVER WHAT I WILL SAY IS
THAT- WE ARE REALLY LOOKING AT
OUR SYSTEMS AND WE'RE LOOKING
AT. WHAT WHAT GAPS WE MAY HAVE
HAD IN OUR SYSTEM A LONG WAY
AND SO ABSOLUTELY TO THE
EXTENT. THAT WE NEED TO DO SOME
COURSE CORRECTION WE HAVE BEEN
WE WILL CONTINUE. CORRECTION I
JUST HAVE A OKAY- SO IN MY
FORMER WIFE I WORKED AT A
NONPROFIT CHILD DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATION AND ONE OF THE
RUNNING JOKES ABOUT CCL WAS
THAT BY THE TIME THEY GOT
AROUND TO INSPECTING A CHILD
CARE CENTER THE CHILDREN WOULD
HAVE AGED OUT OF THAT CENTER-
IT WAS UNDERFUNDED THEY DID NOT
HAVE ENOUGH INSPECTORS AND SO
THIS WAS A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO-
SO CAN YOU CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THAT IN TERMS OF. I'M VERY
CURIOUS ABOUT ACTUALLY HOW
INSPECTIONS HAPPEN NOW OVER
ZOOM I JUST WONDER ABOUT THE
ABILITY TO GET REALLY ACCURATE
AN ACUTE INFORMATION BUT THEN
I'M ALSO WONDERING ABOUT SORT
OF THE STAFFING AND BACKLOG-
AND YOUR ABILITY TO MAKE
INSPECTIONS- IN A TIMELY
FASHION. IF THAT'S CHANGED YEAH
NO ABSOLUTELY- OUR TEAM
ABSOLUTELY HAS REQUESTED MORE
RESOURCES OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS AND WE HAVE STEPPED UP
AND INCREASED OUR ABILITY TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO OUR FACILITIES
BOTH IN TERMS OF OUR INSPECTION
PROCESS WHICH WE HAVE IMPROVED
ON- WE'VE TAKEN A LOOK THROUGH
A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
UNIVERSITY YES YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT OUR INSPECTION
TOOL AND MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
MORE ROBUST AND WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE FACILITIES IN A
DIFFERENT WAY AND DID
PREVIOUSLY ALSO I WILL SAY
DURING THE PANDEMIC. I KNOW
THAT- THERE WAS SOME
ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE WEREN'T
GOING OUT TO FACILITY AND
CERTAINLY WHERE AS WE DID AND
SOME OF OUR ACTIVITIES THAT
WERE IN PERSPECTIVE FOR THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THOSE
RESIDENTS AT THE FACILITIES
THAT'S WELL ASK. WERE ON STAFF
THANK YOU WE WERE STILL
RESPONDING IN PERSON TO TYPE
ONE AND TYPE TWO-
INVESTIGATIONS WHICH ARE
ESSENTIALLY THINGS THAT ARE
MORE EGREGIOUS AND REALLY DO
REQUIRE THAT IN PERSON
APPROACHED MY LIFE IN OCTOBER
STATE AND SO WE DID NOT AND
GOING OUT INTO FACILITIES ONLY
AND WE DO INTEND THREE ZERO ARE
IN FIRST PERSON INFECTIONS IN
APRIL- I WILL JUST SAY YOU KNOW
BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE WITH THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES-
DIRECTOR PREVIOUSLY AND AS A AS
A CARE PROVIDER- DATE I DO KNOW
ABSOLUTELY WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN TERMS OF B. THE
PERCEPTION OF LICENSING AND I
WILL SAY THAT OUR DIRECTOR
DIRECTOR JOHNSON WHO DID. COME
FROM THE CHILD I TITLED HEARD
BACKGROUND WAS ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED IN SOME OF THE
RESTRUCTURING SHE'S DONE IN THE
DEPARTMENT TO BE ABLE TO PRINT
SURE THAT WE ARE BEING READ ON
THAT I'M NOT ONLY IN PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE OR
TRAINING FOR FACILITIES BUT IN
TERMS OF PAYING THE- OVERSIGHT
AND FIRST I ROLE. THAT WE TAKE
pABSOLUTE COMMITTED TO ENSURING
WE'RE DOING THINGS AND THE TIME
WAY IN A CALM. WAY FROM. OUR
LIFE. FIRST AHA. AND THEN FOR.
MIGHT FIND QUESTION IS AROUND
THE ADULT AND SENIOR FOR- MANY
THEM ARE COMING OFF. PEOPLE
HAVE CHALLENGES WITH HOW THE
RATES ARE SO LOW- 'VE ACTUALLY
SEEN A LOT OF THIS HAPPEN I MY
OWN DISTRICT- AND SO JUST
WANTED YOUR THOUGHTS ON WHAT
YOU'RE- NOW DOING TO. MAKE SURE
THAT OUR SENIORS AND VULNERABLE
ADULTS ARE ABLE TO STAY IN
THESE FACILITIES IS THERE A
PLAN- SOME SORT OF PRACTICES
AND POLICIES THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO EMPLOY. YEAH ABSOLUTELY SO
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC WE
CERTAINLY ONCE AGAIN HAD TO
BALANCE OUR ROLE OF PRESERVING
OUR FACILITIES ENSURING THAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO SUSTAIN
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC AND EVEN
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC INSURING
THAT WE HAD. ENOUGH
OPPORTUNITIES AND ARE
CONTINUING TO CARE FOR AGING
AND DISABLED ADULTS TO BE ABLE
TO MEET THEIR THEIR HOUSING
NEEDS IN THEIR LONG TERM. AND
THROUGH THE MASTER AN AGING OUR
DEPARTMENTS AND HEAVILY
INVOLVED IN LOOKING AT
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE MAY HAVE
A STATE TO BE ABLE TO WORK AND
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES THOSE IN
YOUR LONG TERM CARE
OPPORTUNITY. FOR ADULTS AND
SENIORS- WE HAVE SEEN EVEN
THOUGH THE NUMBER OF FACILITIES
THAT SERVE OUR SFI COMMUNITY-
HAS INCREASED OVER TIME WE HAVE
SEEN A DECREASE. IN FOLKS
RECEIVING SSI ARE LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE RESIDING IN
THOSE FACILITIES AND THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY A CONCERN FOR US
BECAUSE WE DO WANT TO ENSURE
THEIR- ARGUS LADIES HAVE THAT
THE FUNDING AND THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO REALLY HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SERVE THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS SINCE
THE- ONE SUCH OPPORTUNITY IS
THE COMMUNITY CARE EXPANSION
PLANS- WHICH IS BEING PROPOSED.
TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST OUR
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY AND OUR ADULT
RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES TO BE
ABLE TO- PURCHASED THEIR
FACILITIES THIS WOULD BE
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS ARE
PURCHASED AS- AS ONE
OPPORTUNITY TO OFFSET THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH OPERATING THESE
FACILITIES. WE'RE ALSO
EXPLORING SEVERAL OTHER OPTIONS
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO HELP WITH
THIS AND I'M SHOULD THERE BE
ANY PROPOSALS THAT WOULD. BE
AND THAT MAY REVISED. OKAY I
YOU KNOW I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- RESPONSE. I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT I WAS SO ALARMED
ARM KIND OF LOOKING INTO- THE
REPORTS AROUND THESE YOUNG
FOLKS AND THE ABUSES- AND THE
DEATH I CERTAINLY HOPE THAT.
YOU ALL WERE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO REVAMP THE
DEPARTMENT BEFORE AN ARTICLE
CAME OUT IT'S ALWAYS SUSPECT TO
ME WHEN FOLKS DECIDE TO MAKE
CHANGES YOU KNOW AFTER
SOMETHING ABOUT IN THE NEWS IT
AND MAKES PEOPLE QUESTION-
THEIR TRUST AND DEPARTMENTS AND
IN GOVERNMENT AND WHY THINGS
AREN'T BEING ADDRESSED BEFORE.
AN INVESTIGATIVE REPORT COMES
OUT BUT- IT ALSO REALLY HAS
INFORMED AND AFFIRMS THE WORK
THAT IS HAPPENING BY SO MANY
FOLKS IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY
SPEAR SPEAR. AROUND RAMA INFORM
SYSTEMS AND YOU KNOW HOW WE
WORK AND LOOK MORE
COMPREHENSIVELY AND
COMPASSIONATELY. AT THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM YOU KNOW
IF OUR CHILDREN GROW UP AND
ACTUALLY CREATE HARM. WE GUILTY
IF IT'S BECAUSE WE'VE ALLOWED
THEM TO BE TREATED THIS WAY-
AND THAT'S HOW I KIND OF SEE
THIS SO I'M HOPEFUL THAT- MORE.
AGGRESSIVE CHANGES AND
REFLECTION WILL BE HAPPENING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT SO THAT WE
DON'T CONTINUE TO- GET STORIES
LIKE THIS IN HERE ABOUT THE
DEATHS OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU I DO HOPE
TO BRING MY- SOCIAL SERVICE
BACKGROUND AND EXPERIENCE IN
OVERSEEING CHILD WELFARE IN ART
AMERICANS COUNTY TO THE TABLE
HERE TO INFORM COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING I'M ALSO APPRECIATIVE
EYES CENTER COME LONGER AND AB
ONE EIGHTEEN THAT I KNOW. YOU
ARE WORKING ON WITH OUR
DEPARTMENTS TO FIND OTHER
STRATEGIES FOR TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE AND BRAND BRINGING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CRISIS THE
ESCALATION AND- INTERFACING
WITH UNITY'S PRIOR TAX LAW
ENFORCEMENT YOU NEED TO GET
INVOLVED I THINK THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF. WORK AND
LOOK FORWARD. TO PARTNERSHIP IN
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU SENATE.
SENATOR GROWTH. THANK YOU MADAM
PRO TEM- THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
LOS ANGELES AFTER OF QUITE A
FEW QUESTIONS THAT I WAS GOING
TO ASK SO I JUST WANT TO FOLLOW
UP JUST A LITTLE BIT- YOU KNOW
I UNDERSTAND ABOUT THE
FACILITIES THAT REALIZE THAT
WERE- CERTIFIED OUT OF STATE
WHERE WE HAD TRAGEDIES TAKE
PLACE. I'D LIKE TO KNOW IF YOU
HAVE THE INFORMATION WHAT
HAPPENED TO THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT WERE THERE AND WHAT'S
THEIR STATUS NOW. THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION SENATOR GROPED.
WE HAVE BEEN TRACKING ALONG
WITH COUNTIES SO. JUST A JUST A
BACK UP A LITTLE BIT COUNTIES
ARE THE PLACE IN AGENCIESFOR
THE NEXT YEAR AND AS SUCH. THEY
ARE- THE ENTITIES THAT COLLECT
INFORMATION ABOUT YOU AND THEIR
WHEREABOUTS ARE OUT ON. THE THE
INFORMATION THAT WE GET THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT THE THIRD
PICTURE THESE. HAVE BEEN
THROUGH OUR PARTNERSHIP AND
REPORTING THAT COUNTIES HAVE
DONE. AND WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
THE DATA OF THAT A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE UNITS THAT WERE
OUT OF STATE A HUNDRED THIRTY
YOU ARE NOW BACK IN CALIFORNIA.
ON THE MAJORITY OF THOSE ARE
EITHER IN. HAVE GONE HOME TO
RELATIVES RELATIVE PLACEMENTS
ORDER ARE IN PHASE THESE ARE
RESOURCE FAMILIES OUR FOSTER
FAMILIES. OR IN CHIU S. T. R.
T. NEEDS WHICH ARE SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT PROGRAM
FOR FOSTER YOUTH OF THE
MAJORITY OF YOU HAVE RETURNED
THE OTHER. SETTING SOME OF THE
YOU HAVE RETURN TO STUDY THAT
WE- DID NOT REALLY HAVE A
HEALTHCARE HAD BUILD OF A
RESULT SO. FOR INSTANCE I AM
YOUR KEEP USER WINE AND IT'S-
WRAPAROUND ARE HIGH- THAT THOSE
ARE THE TYPE OF SERVICES THAT
KNOW WE STILL HAVE CONTINUE. TO
BUILD CONTAINED OUT FOR. AND
THEN WE DO HAVE SOME YEARS WHO
HAVE TURNED INTO WHAT WE- WE'RE
CHARACTERIZING AS MORE
UNDESIRABLE SITUATIONS- THANKS
ASK. THEM YOU NEEDED OFFENSIVE.
ATTORNEYS WERE PROBATION HERE.
AT COMMITTED NEW OFFENSES AND
HAD TO BE RETURNED. HOLD ON TO
THEM YOU ARE HAVE GONE AWOL AND
BURST OUT OF THE COUNTIES ARE
STILL LOOKING FOR THEIR VIEWS
AND SO. WE ARE DEFINITELY
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
COUNTIES AND PROVIDED. CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH COUNTIES WE NOW
UNTIL EVERYONE OF THOSE UNITS
IS IN A STABLE PLACEMENT IN
SITUATION OUR WORK WILL BE DONE
ON THE SHOULD BE FOR SHARE
QUESTION. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR THAT INFORMATION- THIS
IS GONNA SOUND LIKE A POLITICAL
QUESTION BUT IT REALLY IS NOT-
THE UNDERSECRETARY OF THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION- FOR
HHS ANDERTON- MISTER CESAR.
WITH THE A WHAT A REMARKABLE
WOMAN BY THE NAME OF LYNN
JOHNSON. AND SHE- SHE HAS A HAD
A PLAN- WHICH WE HAVE LOOKED
AT. IN MY OFFICE TO FIND
FOREVER HOMES RIGHT EVEN THOSE
THAT ARE EMANCIPATED AND THOSE
THAT- YOU KNOW FOSTER YOUTH ARE
EMANCIPATED. YOU KNOW YOUTH.
EVEN AFTER EIGHTEEN YEARS OLDER
TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD THEY STILL
NEED A PLACE TO GO OUT
THANKSGIVING DINNER THEY STILL
NEED ADVICE THEY STILL NEED ALL
THESE THINGS. M. AND I KNOW
THAT YOU HAVE- YOU SOME OF OUR
SOME OF OUR YOUTH THAT ARE IN
THE PROGRAMS THAT YOU SERVICE
IS THERE ANY PLAN THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS TO PROVIDE- AT
TO REALLY REALLY PROVIDE. OF
HOMES FOR THESE FOSTER YOUTH
AND- AND FOREVER HOMES I GUESS
IS MY QUESTION. YEAH I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION CENTER
GROVE AND I ABSOLUTELY AGREE
WITH YOU- ANY USE ESPECIALLY A
YOUTH WHO'S BEEN IN FOSTER CARE
REALLY DESERVES A FAMILY
FOREVER- UP THAT THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE DEVELOP WITHIN OUR
DEPARTMENT REALLY FALL UNDER
THE LEADERSHIP OF CHIEF DEPUTY
JUDGE FLORIDA WHERE THESE TYPES
OF PROGRAMS WHAT I WHAT I CAN
SAY FROM A LICENSING
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT. TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN BUILD OUT
MODELS THAT CREATE- MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU TO BE
ABLE TO FIND SUPPORT NETWORKS
ACROSS THE SPAN OF THEIR LIVES
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY- WORKING
ALONG SIDE BOTH ARE COUNTY
PARTNERS ARE STAKEHOLDERS AND-
PRIVATE PROVIDERS AS WELL AS
THE OTHER DIVISIONS WITHIN.
CDSS TO DO. AND WOULD BE HAPPY
TO BACK TO YOU WITH MORE. ABOUT
SOME OF THE STRATEGIES AND SOME
OF THE SUPPORT THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING ARE CONSIDERING. A
PRE SHAPE THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- CENTER LAYERED. WELL ONE
THE CENTER BATES AND I SERVED
IN THE ASSEMBLY THERE WAS ONE
OF HER COLLEAGUES FROM ORANGE
COUNTY. BY THE TIME HE WAS
DONE. HAD APPEARED TO HAVE
EVERY JOB KNOWN TO HUMANKIND.
AND I HAVE AGED INTO THAT CAR
SO I'VE WORKED FOR OUR LOCAL
SOCIAL SERVICES DEPARTMENT FOR
FEW YEARS. AND LET ME JUST SAY
I APPRECIATED- CENTER CALM
WATERS QUESTIONS THEY REALLY
MATTERED WHAT I WOULD ASK I
THINK YOU'RE EMINENTLY
QUALIFIED NINE LOOK FORWARD TO
VOTING FOR YOUR CONFIRMATION I
DON'T HAVE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU AND-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
QATARI IF PROBABLY ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT DEPARTMENTS THAT
WE HAVE IN IN OUR STATE IN
TERMS OF REACHING OUT TO THOSE
WHO PROBABLY HAVEN'T BEEN
PROVIDED THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
AND MAYBE THE REST OF US HAVE
AND YOUR JOB IS TO LIFT THEM UP
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE OUT-
INTO WHAT IS THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM LET'S SAY AND I ONCE UPON
A TIME. I WAS THERE DOING THAT
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OF THE MATTER OF FACT SO
I KNOW THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE
THERE I RECENTLY BEEN VERY
INVOLVED IN THE SITUATION WITH
THE RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES
AND THE DIMINISHMENT OF THOSE
CUT BY MY BROTHER GOD REST HIS
SOUL HE DID PASS AWAY THAT IT
WAS VERY DIFFICULT TO FIND A
PLACE FOR HIM- BECAUSE HE
NEEDED- HE HE BELIEVES HE LIVE.
MORE INDEPENDENT THAN WHAT THAT
SAY THAT THAT TIE IN HARRODS-
ACTUALLY CASH BUT NOTHING ELSE
SO WE WERE GOING THROUGH THE
CASH LIKE CRAZY IN FACT HE DID
PASS AWAY. YOU KNOW JUST BEFORE
KOBE AND I IT WAS PROBABLY A
BLESSING BECAUSE HE WAS HAD
REALLY DETERIORATED AT THAT
TIME THAT IF HE HAD LVED MUCH
LONGER WE WOULD HAVE RUN OUT OF
MONEY AND THE FACILITY OPERATED
TOLD ME HE WOULD HAVE TO BE TO
A MEDIC CAL. OUR SITUATION AND
THERE WAS NOTHING IN THE REGION
SO I AM REALLY CONCERNED AND
I'M I LIKE THE QUESTION THAT
SENATOR COM LONGER AFTER ON
THIS VERY ISSUE THAT WE ARE
REALLY WORKING HARD TO FIND
PLACES ARE FOR PEOPLE WHO DO
USE UP ALL OF THEIR RESOURCES
AND FIND THEMSELVES IN THAT
SITUATION BECAUSE THERE'S NO
PLACE TO MOVE THEM. SO THE
QUESTION WOULD BE DO THEY
BECOME PART OF THE HUGE GROWING
HOME ENOUGH YEAH WHO HAVE THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE NOT THAT THEY
HAVE SUBSTANCE ABUSE NOT THAT
THEY HAVE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
THEY JUST DON'T HAVE MONEY TO
SUPPORT THEMSELVES AND PERHAPS
NO FAMILY THAT CAN STEP BEYOND.
SO I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
FOCUSING ON THAT I KNOW THERE'S
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IF I LOOK AT THE BUDGET.
CORRECTLY THAT'S BEING ERECTED
TO WORK WITH THE- DOT. TO A-
REHABILITATE SOME. THIS THAT.
ARE NEED THAT. REHABILITATION
THAT NEED FREE REMOTE. SO-
PLEASE LET ME PER. ON I DON'T
HAVE THE PRO. RIGHT NOW LIFT IT
FALLS ON A SUNDAY I HOPE NOT.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME I WISH YOU
WELL I KNOW THAT TO YOUR
BACKGROUND SHOWS THAT YOU HAVE
A- DEEP COMMITMENT. OF FOR THIS
WORK AND DID THAT FOR A VERY
IMPORTANT IN THIS WORK SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT SERVICE. AND I AM
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES- I WILL JUST WRAP UP
BEFORE WE GET MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. I TO REALLY APPRECIATED
THE QUESTIONS. FROM SENATOR COM
LONGER I MAY START WITH HER
EVERY TIME FRANKLY YEAH.
BECAUSE IT YEAH HI- AND MY
STAFF HAVE BEEN TRACKING VERY
CLOSELY. THE RETURN OF THOSE
YOUNG. FOLKS TO CALIFORNIA A
NUMBER OF MY OWN MONEY I
UNDERSTAND THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND THE
COUNTIES- THIS PARTICULAR.
RULES COMMITTEE HAS THREE
MEMBERS THAT ARE ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT. AND AS IT RELATES TO THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES I SORT OF
FOUND IT. ASTOUNDING THAT THE
STATE THE SIZE OF CALIFORNIA
WITH FORTY MILLION PEOPLE IN
THE MOST. KIND OF PROGRESSIVE
APPROACH TO SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS. HAD OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
OUT OF STATE TO BEGIN WITH AND
SO YOUR COMMENTS AND I HAVE TO
SAY HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE. YOUR
ANSWERING ALL THOSE QUESTIONS
SEEMINGLY JUST IN CONVERSATION
WITHOUT HAVING TO. LOOK AT
RESEARCHER NOTES- BECAUSE IT
MEANS YOU ARE IN MY MIND IT
MEANS YOU ARE. CLOSE TO THESE
ISSUES AND I WILL TELL YOU THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES- PROVIDE SO MANY
SERVICES CRITICAL TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE VULNERABLE WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING SENIORS OUR YOUTH. AND
SO I'M GOING TO CONTINUE TO
TRACK THAT PROGRAM BECAUSE I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE
AND THE COUNTIES IN TERMS OF
FINDING THOSE THOSE PLACEMENTS.
AND AND I THINK IT'S INCUMBENT
UPON US AS WE SIT HERE AND ASK
THESE QUESTIONS WHICH ARE
GREATLY APPRECIATE- THAT WE
TAKE THAT INTO OUR ROLE AS AS
BUDGET AS WE CAN. CLEARLY RIGHT
NOW- SO AND WE E. A YOU KNOW
WE'RE SEEING YOUR APPOINTMENT
TODAY. ARE A REMINDER BECAUSE
WE HAVE HAD SOME MOVEMENT IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE. THAT WE
WERE ABLE IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY TO SUPPORT YOUR YOUR
PARTNER YOUR COUNTERPART DEPUTY
CHIEF- TROYA. ON THESE ISSUES
AS WELL SO I THINK WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO LOOK IN TRACK AND
TRY TO BE SUPPORTIVE. I WANT TO
ADD EVEN THOUGH I KNOW THAT YOU
WEREN'T IN THIS POSITION AT
THAT TIME BUT SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
AS OUR GOVERNOR WAS COMING INTO
OFFICE AND GOVERNOR BROWN WAS
GOING OUT. I REPRESENT- SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND WE HAD OF
COURSE ASYLUM SEEKERS AND A
CRISIS AT THE BORDER. OF TRYING
TO HELP PEOPLE GET- ESTABLISHED
IN INTO THE- TO THE ACT THERE
ARE SPONSORS ARE NOT ALWAYS AND
OBVIOUSLY SAN DIEGO OR
CALIFORNIA. AND I REMEMBERS
CHRISTMAS ARE BEING ON ON
CHRISTMAS EVE AND CHRISTMAS
ACTUALLY CHRISTMAS DAY. OUT
WITH YOUR STAFF YOUR YOUR STAFF
ARE SOME OF THE MOST INCREDIBLE
VOLUNTEERS TO VOLUNTEER THEIR
TIME TO GO DOWN TO THE BORDER.
AND PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES- I
YOU KNOW AS STAFF MEMBERS IN
THE STATE AND HOW CONSISTENT
THEY WERE SO I'M FOREVER
APPRECIATIVE FOR THAT ARE. AND
HOPE THAT WE CAN BE SUPPORTIVE
OF YOUR WORK AND I AM
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR
APPOINTMENT TODAY. BUT WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC SO THEY CAN- WEIGH IN AS
WELL. AND WITH THAT- ARE YOU
HAVE MY APPRECIATION AND THANKS
FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE RESUME AS
WELL THANK YOU MANAGER- WE'RE
GOING TO START IN THE ROOM HERE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT AND- ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE I DON'T SEE ANYONE
IT OF THE FROM THE PUBLIC HERE.
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
SO I WILL LOOK TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. WE KEEP AN EYE ON ROOM
ONE TWELVE AND I DON'T SEE
ANYONE THEIR APPROACH IN THE
DIET SO I AM GOING TO- GO BACK
TO OUR MODERATOR WHO'S BEEN
WAITING PATIENTLY. TO SEE IF
THERE ARE MEMBERS ON
TELECONFERENCE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO WEIGH IN SUPPORT ARE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I AM CURRENTLY
OUT FIVE IN Q. FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND YOUR
MEMBERS SEVERAL. GO AHEAD OF
THE AFTERNOON. REPRESENTING A
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE PAIR FOR
PROVIDERS. I'M GONNA I'M GONNA
STOP YOU RIGHT NOW CAN I CAN I
ASK YOU STOP ONLY BECAUSE WE
ARE HAVING A VERY BAD
CONNECTION AND WE CAN'T HEAR
YOU SO I'M GOING TO- INTEREST
IN ORDER FOR CAN'T PICK IT UP
SO I'M GOING TO TRY AGAIN AND
SEE IF YOU CAN INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AGAIN AND IF IT'S
CLEARER IF NOT I MAY STOP YOU
AGAIN I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY. BUT WE
REALLY WANT TO HEAR YOUR
TESTIMONY SO START AGAIN AND
LET'S SEE IF IT'S BETTER. AT
LEAST MANAGER CAN HEAR ME NOW.
A LITTLE BETTER KEEP TALKING
AND WE WILL SEE. GO AHEAD OKAY
THIS IS BEVERLY YOU. GOT IT GO
AHEAD ON BEHALF OF UEW AFTER ME
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY.
REPRESENTING A HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND HOME CARE AND CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS AND THIRTY NINE
COUNTIES. WE ARE THRILLED TODAY
TO SUPPORT MEDICAL SORRY WHAT
MADE YOU CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF EDS THAT. THE PANDEMIC
HAPPENED A EASY FOR MEMBERSHIP
OUR FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
BASED CLOSURE. RAPIDLY EVOLVING
POLICIES AND THE NEED FOR
PANDEMIC SUPPORT AND RELIEF. IN
OUR EXPERIENCE MCCARTY HAS BEEN
A TRUE PARTNER THROUGHOUT THE
TIME PROVIDING OPEN LIKE
COMMUNICATE. HELPING
FACILITATE. MY SHARP PROVIDERS
THE PLATE. IS AND WILL BE A
WHAT THEY CALL THE NINETEENTH
HAS BEEN PRIORITY AND ACCESS TO
BACK THINGS WERE WORKFORCE. WE
ARE TRULY GRATEFUL. FOR I LIVE
WORK AND FORTY- AND ASK. IT
MISS YOU YOU WE LOS A LITTLE
BIT AT THE END BUT I THINK WE
GOT THE GIST OF IT- AS BEST WE
COULD I'M SORRY TO OUR STERN
ARMOR FOR WE WILL SEE ABOUT THE
NEXT- PERSON TO SEE IF THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES BUT MISS
YOU WE DID HERE. AW PRETTY
MUCH. 99% OF YOUR TESTIMONY-
MADAM MODERATOR LET'S SEE HOW
IT GOES WITH THE NEXT SPEAKER.
THANK YOU ONLINE THIRTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. FIFTY
ARMSTRONG UP ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE THIS.
CAN IT AT A CALIFORNIA. CAN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE QATARIS
NOMINATION. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MADAME
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU RYAN TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS BOXING AND
GOLD. REPRESENTING SIX BAGS. AN
ASSOCIATION OF RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITY FOR THE ELDERLY. AND
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED. AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
QATARIS CONFIRMATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAME
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. THANK
YOU LINE FORTY TWO TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HUNTINGTON SHARP ON THE
HELICOPTERS DISTANCE. ADJUSTED
LETTING OUR STRONG SUPPORT
MCCARTY IN ADDITION. THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU
LINE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
IS PROFOUND AND MEMBERS THIS IS
HEATHER HARRISON WITH PEE
CALIFORNIA ASSISTED LIVING
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT LIKE
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND WE'RE VERY CLEAN
RECORD DEFINED QATARIS
APPOINTMENT AS DEPUTY DIRECTOR
YOUR SHE STARTED. WE
CHALLENGING TURN OUT AND SHE
HASN'T- SHIED AWAY FROM ANY
PARTY. AND VERY ARE SOLUTION
ORIENTED AND RESPONSIVE- YOU
ALL STAKEHOLDERS WE APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING YOU ARE AND LOOK
pFORWARD TO WORKING WITH FOR THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU RYAN
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM BROKE. THAT UP
IN MY NAME MY FIRST YEAR THERE
IN CALIFORNIA OKAY MA'AM LET ME
LET ME STOP YOU. EXCUSE ME I'M
SO SORRY I HATE TO INTERRUPT
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC- WE ARE
HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES SO I'M GOING TO
ASK YOU IF YOU WOULD START
AGAIN AND WHAT SEEMS TO BE
HELPFUL IS IF YOU SLOW DOWN
YOUR CONVERSATION AND SPEAK
CLEARLY INTO THE PHONE I
APOLOGIZE FOR THIS- DIFFICULTY
BUT WE WANT TO GET YOUR
TESTIMONY. SO IF YOU WILL START
AGAIN AND MAYBE SLOW DOWN NO
PROBLEM THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM GROUP. HE MY
NEXT MINUTE BRUSHING DIRECT
AFFECT EIGHT IT THAT YEAH AND
WE'RE WITH THE MAY IT'S NOT
WITH HAVE ROCKED ARI AT IF THAT
ACTOR FOR THE. HE LOVES YOU AND-
NINETY FIVE FEET HEARD THAT IT
TO THE REST PROGRAM LEADERSHIP
AND OUR PUBLIC ACCOUNT WITHIN
TO GET YOU THE AND WE'RE TO. IN
YOU- WELL THAT SHE THAT PRETTY
THINKS A RESPECTABLE ASK REASON
FOR HER. THANK YOU. MATAMATA IS
THERE NEXT WE- THANK YOU I HAVE
NO MORE COMMON THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
HAVING HEARD FROM SUPPORTERS WE
WILL GO TO MEMBERS WHO MIGHT BE
IN OPPOSITION AND BACK IT TO
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE AND
I SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE AT THIS TIME I WILL LOOK
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE AGAIN. I SEE
NO ONE I THEIR OB SO MADAM
MODERATOR FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IT MIGHT BE IN
OPPOSITION I'M COMING BACK TO
YOU. NOW. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE COMMENTED OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. MADAME MODERATOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR A MOTION I WOULD
MOVE. SENATOR LAYERED MAKES A
MOTION TO SUPPORT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FOURTEEN CAN I ARE WE STILL IN
SUBJECT MATTER HI YET WE ARE
VOTING YES RIGHT NOW WE JUST
MADE THE MOTION WE'VE HEARD OF
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF WERE ON
A MOTION FOR ASA MISCARRY. YES
I THANK YOU THAT I. AND JUST
FOR MY OWN THOUGH THIS WAS
ANGELA DAVIS ARE YOU ALREADY
HAVE A YES- TWO MEMBERS TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO'S
LISTENING- SENATOR GROVE IS- DO
WOULD DOUBLE DUTY RIGHT NOW SHE
IS AT THE RULES COMMITTEE AND
RUNNING INTO THE CHAMBER FOR
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE AS WELL
SO. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE SHE
KNOWS WHO WERE VOTNG ON AT THE
MOMENT. SO EYES- WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR LAYERED
OFFER A DEPUTY CHIEF ATARI SO-
MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
GROWTH I WROTE I KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER RA LAYERED FIVE
THERE'D AYE BATES FIVE EIGHT I
ATKINS HI I CAN SIGN IT IS
UNANIMOUS AND THE DEPUTY CHIEF
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY SENATORS
ABSOLUTELY- LET ME JUST LOOK
AND WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
NEXT OUR PARTY WANNA OKAY. I AM
GOING TO ASK STAFF- IF THERE IS
ANY NEED THAT WE NEED TO CHECK
ON THIS TECHNICAL OKAY I AM
WHILE WE HEAR THE OPENING OF
THE NEXT PERSON BECAUSE THAT
WAS PRETTY DIFFICULT FOR OUR
STENOGRAPHER TO HEAR I KNOW WE
DID THE BEST WE COULD I THINK
WE GOT ALMOST EVERYBODY'S
TESTIMONY. TELECONFERENCE WISE
OF OVER A YOU KNOW WE WERE ABLE
TO GET IT BUT IT WAS A LITTLE
HARD TO HEAR- WE'RE GOING TO GO
NOW TO ITEM ONE SEE. AND THAT
WOULD BE THE APPOINTMENT OF
MISS ANDY. MU DIREC I. CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
LET ME SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE YOUR
INCREDIBLE PATIENCE AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING WITH US TODAY.
LET ME INVITE YOU TO- MAKE
OPENING COMMENTS FEEL FREE TO
RECOGNIZE ANYONE THAT MIGHT BE
WITH YOU ARE THE SUPPORT YOU
AND THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS SO
WELCOME. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON. I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
THANKS TO THE GOVERNOR- THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES ADMINISTRATION. MY
FABULOUS COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
AND MANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY- WITH ME BIRCH THING
IS MY FATHER CHARLES NEW JERK
ALL THE WAY FROM MY HOMETOWN OF
DETROIT MICHIGAN- MADE LOCAL
FAMILY DON HUGHES AND SAM
HUGHES. AS A TRANSGENDER WOMAN
WHO. WAS BORN WITH A
SIGNIFICANT DISABILITY AND THE
CHILD OF A HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR
WHO CAME TO THIS COUNTRY AS A
REFUGEE. I AM INCREDIBLY PROUD
TO WORK FOR A DEPARTMENT- WHOSE
MISSION INVOLVES EMPLOYMENT
INDEPENDENCE AND EQUALITY FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. ARE
AFTER US. AN OVER THIRTY YEAR
CAREER WORKING AS A CIVIL
RIGHTS ATTORNEY- I WANTED TO
COME TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- BECAUSE I HAVE WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT. ON
VARIOUS EMPLOYMENT ISSUES
SEEKING TO FURTHER EMPLOYMENT
FOR PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
SERVED AS CHIEF COUNSEL OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN. MAY I
HAVE THE HONOR AND PRIVILEGE OF
ACTING AS CHIEF DEPUTY STARTING
LAST JANUARY- AND ALSO THE
HONOR OF BEING APPOINTED AS THE
CHIEF KATHY IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHTH FROM HAVING GROWN
UP WITH THE A SIGNIFICANT
DISABILITY I HAD THE BENEFIT
OF. SUPPORTS AND SERVICES
THROUGH THE SCHOOL SYSTEM. HI
UNDER WHEN IT WORK EXPERIENCE-
UNDER A FEDERAL PROGRAM THE
DOCTOR RIDDLE MENTIONED SIDA-
OFFERING- SUPPORTS FOR PEOPLE
ARE FROM LOW INCOME BACKGROUNDS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
AND FROM THAT EXPERIENCE I KNEW
HOW IMPORTANT IT WAS ARE FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES TO- BE
OFFERED THE OPPORTUNITY D. TO
WORK. I ULTIMATELY TO OUT
SCHOOL AND DEVOTED MY MIKE TO
SUR THAT. COMMUNITY AND AGAIN I
CROWDEN ON TO BE HERE- YEAH I
THINK HE FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- WELL SENATOR
KAMLAGER WOULD YOU LIKE TO KICK
US OFF AGAIN YOU DID SO WELL
LAST TIME ARE YOU SURPRISED ALL
OF US FROM HAVING TO ASK THE
QUESTION WHY THEY LIEU ASK SO
THIS MAY BE A BURDEN TO. BEAR I
WILL GIVE IT ANOTHER GO THANK
YOU- PRO. MADAM CHAIR WELL I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER.
MODRIC FOR YOUR- CONTINUES
SERVICE I ONLY HAVE A- A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS FOR YOU- YOU KNOW
I WANTED TO START BY SAYING I
HAVE A STEP SON WHO WAS-
DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM AT A VERY.
YOUNG AGE AND SO WE- WORK QUITE
CLOSELY WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTER. AND IN READING OF THE
BINDER ON YOU I WAS STRUCK BY A
CONVERSATION THAT I ACTUALLY IT
HAD SOMETIME AGO WITH A PARENT
OF AN ADULT CHILD WITH
DISABILITIES. AND WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
HIS SON WAS HAVING WITH FINDING
EMPLOYMENT AND FINDING LONG
TERM EMPLOYMENT AND HOW TO
IDENTIFY FRIENDLY EMPLOYERS TO
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY AND
HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT HIS SON-
WOULD NOT BE SHOVED INTO LOW
WAGE. JOBS WITH VERY FEW
PROTECTIONS AND SO I WAS JUST
WONDERING IF YOU COULD SPEAK TO
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE
AND SORT OF YOUR VISION AND THE
WORK THAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING IN
THE DEPARTMENT AROUND KIND OF
PROTECTING THESE COMMUNITIES-
AND ENSURING THAT THEY ALSO
HAVE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO YOU
KNOW DIGNIFIED. LONG TERM
EMPLOYMENT- WHERE YOU KNOW THE
WAGES ARE FAIR- AND WHERE
THERE'S ACTUALLY A RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THAT PARTICULAR ADULT
WITH DISABILITIES AND EVEN- THE
FAMILY MEMBERS OR THE PARENTS
WHO ARE STILL WORKING WITH
THEM- BECAUSE THEY HAPPEN TO
HAVE A DISABILITY. THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR THE QUESTION SO MY
INTEREST AND PASSION IN THIS
AREA DATE- DATES BACK FAR FAR
BEFORE I JOINED THE DEPARTMENT.
AS DEPUTY DIRECTOR DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA I LED AN
EFFORT AROUNDIMPROVING
OUTCOMES FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. IN EVEN THOUGH I
GREW UP WITH A DISABILITY I
AND- PRACTICED LAW FOR DECADES
I HAD NO IDEA THAT THERE IS A
FEDERAL LAW AND STATE LAW. THAT
ALLOWED EMPLOYERS TO PAY
CERTAIN PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES LESS THAN MINIMUM
WAGE. AND AND THE RECIPIENTS OF
THOSE WAGES LARGE PART OF
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
WHICH INCLUDES ON AUTISM
SPECTRUM DISORDER- I
PARTICIPATED IN ADVOCACY- THAT
BECAME HE NATIONAL TREND- THE
TO. PROVIDE SUPPORT TO PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES TO
ALLOW THEM TO WORK IN
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT. EARNING A
SUSTAINABLE WAGE AND THAT'S
ACTUALLY HOW I FOUND MY WAY TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION BECAUSE I SAW
THAT PASSION AND COMMITMENT
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT. AS WELL
AS IN OUR SISTER DEPARTMENTS
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- TO ACHIEVE THESE
ENDS AND WE WE'VE BEEN WORKING
FOR MANY YEARS ON THIS EFFORT
WE'VE MADE STRIDES- THERE'S
STILL ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT IN A
WAYS TO GO. AND AND
SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR QUESTION I
THINK IT REALLY INVOLVES
STARTING WITH INDIVIDUALS- WAY
BEFORE THEY'RE READY FOR
EMPLOYMENT- STARTING WITH THE
EXPECTATION THAT CHILDREN IN
YOU WILL WORK WILL IT WILL GO
BEYOND- SECONDARY EDUCATION-
AND- AND IT ALSO INVOLVES SOME
THING THAT'S A ONE OF. ONE OF
OUR AND DEBATE WHICH TO TREAT
BUSINESS AS CLIENT AS A AS A
CONSUMER AND TO SEEK OUT- TO
FIND OUT WHAT THE NEEDS OF
BUSINESSES ARE INTO ADVICE AND
SUPPORT BUSINESSES IN REATING
INCLUSIVE ENVIRONMENTS AND SO I
THINK- REALLY COMPLICATED
ISSUE- MULTIPLE BARRIERS AND-
AND MULTIPLE OPPORTUNITIES- FOR
US TO GROW. AND AND AGAIN WE'RE
NOT WE'RE NOT DONE BUT I THINK
WE'RE WE'RE- WE'RE ON THE RIGHT
PATH. THANK YOU AND THEN MY
FINAL QUESTION. ISRAEL'S IS
ABOUT COVERT I'M TRYING O GET
AWAY FROM COBIT BUT IT'S THANK
THINK IT'S STILL WITH US FOR A
LITTLE WHILE LONGER- I'VE HAD A
LOT OF CONVERSATIONS WITH CARE
GIVERS OF- ADULTS WITH- SEVERE
DISABILITIES. WHO WERE
CHALLENGED DURING COVE IT
BECAUSE OF THE RESTRICTIVE
GUIDELINES THEY WERE YOU KNOW
WEARING MASKS- FOR THOSE THAT
HAVE SINCE RE CHALLENGES WAS
REALLY TOUGH THE CONNECTIVITY
WITH CARE GIVERS- THAT THEN HAD
TO SORT OF HAPPENED VIRTUALLY
OR- SPATIALLY DISTANCE BECAUSE
A CODED- AND JUST WANTED TO
KIND OF. ISSUE IF YOU COULD
SHARE WITH ME LESSONS LEARNED
AS A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC AND
SORT OF WHAT'S BEING DONE
REALLY TO ADDRESS AND
ACCOMMODATE THE NEEDS OF THIS
PARTICULAR- COMMUNITY THAT HAS
DIFFERENT AND VERY UNIQUE
CHALLENGES. AS IT RELATES TO
COLD COBIT AND HOW THEY'RE JUST
ABLE TO LIVE AND MANAGE- AND
THEY'RE NOT REALLY THINGS THAT
WE THINK ABOUT- YOU KNOW FOR
FOLKS WHO ARE ABLE BODIED- BUT
THERE SEEM TO BE SO MUCH
DISJOINTED MESS WITH REGARDS TO
THE GUIDELINES THAT WE WERE
SORT OF PUTTING OUT. AND THEN
MAYBE NOT BEING- ADAPTABLE TO
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY.
ABSOLUTELY NOT NO DOUBT THIS
THIS PAST YEAR'S BEEN
INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING FOR. US
AS A NATION YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
IS A STATE- AND ANALYZE THE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
EXCUSE ME- WE- AS AN ESSENTIAL
SERVICE- PROVIDING- SERVICES TO
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AS
MANY AS- STATE DEPARTMENTS
DETERMINED WE I'M DETERMINED
THAT WE WERE AN ESSENTIAL
SERVICE AND THAT WE WERE NOT
GOING TO CLOSE ANY OF OUR
DOORS. WE KNOW THAT- SERVING
WITH PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
THAT EVERY DISABILITY IS
DIFFERENT AND EVEN WITHIN
DISABILITY TYPES PEOPLE HAVE
UNIQUE NEEDS AND DIFFERENCES
AND OUR PERSPECTIVE IS TO TREAT
PEOPLE INDIVIDUALLY AND MEET
THEM WHERE THEY ARE AND PROVIDE
AND WHAT THEY NEED AND SO. WE
KNOW THAT SOME PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES NEED IN PERSON
SERVICES AND WE- WE WERE
COMMITTED TO KEEPING OUR DOORS
OPEN AND- SINCE THE PANDEMIC
STARTED- OF COURSE WE FOLLOW
ALL GUIDELINES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH- AND- IN PROTECTING THE
COMMUNITY AND IN PROTECTING-
OUR STAFF. SUCH AS SOCIAL
DISTANCING OUR PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AND BOUGHT
AND THE LIKE- WE ALSO VERY
QUICKLY- WHEN AT THE STATE HOME
ORDERS WERE ENTERED MOVED TO-
ALMOST FULL- TELEWORK OR STAFF
WHO WERE NOT REQUIRED TO BE IN
THE OFFICE SO- BEGAN COURTING
CONSUMERS WHO CAME IN AND- TO
THE EXTENT POSSIBLE PER BURKE
SUPPORTING FULL TIME. TELEWORK
OVER 75% OF OUR STAFF OVER THE
PAST YEAR HAVE BEEN-
TELEWORKING- NOT AS YOU'VE
INDICATED NONE OF THE PROVISION
OF SERVICES HAS BEEN PERFECT-
BUT WE HAVE WE HAVE- LEARN SOME
THINGS THROUGH THIS EXPERIENCE
SO WE. WE KNOW NOW- HOW WELL WE
PROVIDE REMOTE SERVICE WHEN
THEY WORK FOR CONSUMERS AND
WHEN AND WHEN THEY'RE
APPROPRIATE AND THERE ARE MANY
BENEFITS TO- I INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SUPPORTS TO- PROVIDE
SERVICES REMOTELY TO CONSUMERS
SO AGAIN. NO NO NO PERFECT
SOLUTION- PARTICULARLY IN THE
IN THE EXAMPLES YOU'RE CITING-
BUT A BUT WE WE'VE WE'VE TRIED
OUR BEST TO- BALANCE MEETING
THE NEEDS OF OUR CONSUMERS. AND
IN PROTECTING ON THE COMMUNITY
SO MUCH AND JUST WANNA SAY
THOSE ARE VERY BEAUTIFUL
FLOWERS THAT YOU HAVE ON YOUR
DESK. MAKING ME VERY HAPPY.
THANK YOU. IT THANK YOU SENATOR
CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THE SENATE PRO TEM A
CALLING ON OUR COLLEAGUES FROM
LOS ANGELES BECAUSE SHE CAN ASK
THE QUESTIONS THAT- THAT I HAD
LAID OUT AS WELL THAT SAVES
TIME I HAVE A BIG HEART FOR THE
DD COMMUNITY I WAS ABLE TO
SERVE AND I JUST HAVE ONE WHEN
I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY AND- JUST
FELL IN LOVE WITH A COMMUNITY
THAT TO THEM. THIS IS A GET THE
SERVICE THAT IT DESERVES-
RECENTLY WE HAD DEAD JIM
BALDWIN IN OUR LOCAL KERN
COUNTY BAKERSFIELD ARC RETIRE I
THINK HIS BIGGEST- HIS BIGGEST
ACCOMPLISHMENT AND HIS BIGGEST
OUR ROLE IN THE ART THE
BAKERSFIELD ARC WAS TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERY INDIVIDUAL OR
CONSUMER THAT WAS IN THAT
FACILITY. I FELT A SENSE OF
PRIDE- BY TRYING TO GETTING
THEM EMPLOYED- AND I KNOW THAT
IS THE MISSION OF PROVIDING
EMPLOYMENT AND INDEPENDENCE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
IS THAT IS- ON YOUR TOP TEN
LIST IF NOT TALK. TO LAST. A
BIT IN THE RESPONSE IN THE
RULES COMMITTEE PACKET. YOU
SAID THAT- BASICALLY 70% OF
INDIVIDUALS BETWEEN THE AGES OF
SIXTEEN AND SIXTY FOUR STILL
UNEMPLOYED- CAN YOU TELL ME
WHAT YOU THINK THOSE BARRIERS
ARE AND- HAS ANY LEGISLATION IN
THE PAST AFFECTED THAT
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE TO ME THAT'S A LOT HIGHER
THAN IT WAS WHEN I. THEN WHEN I
WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU
SENATOR- ABSOLUTELY IT'S AN
UNACCEPTABLE PERCENTAGE AND
THAT'S THAT'S WHY THE-DEPARTMENT REHABILITATION OR
VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION. OUR
PARTNERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
EXISTS- WE HAVE YOU KNOW WE
LEARN CONTINUOUSLY AND WE MAKE
CHANGES CONTINUOUSLY TO SEEK
TO. IMPROVE THOSE EFFORTS- WE-
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN WE ARE.
UNDER A FEDERAL MANDATE WE
BELIEVE. IN BECAUSE IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO WE'VE HAD A
I'M MORE FOCUSED- EFFORTS TO
ENGAGE EMPLOYERS. AND TO-
CONSIDER EMPLOYERS AS US
CLIENTS AND PROVIDE THEM WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
ADVICE- AND TO PARTNER WITH AND
TO. TO EMPLOY PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES- I DON'T KNOW- THE
TRAJECTORY OF THE PERCENTAGE
AND WHETHER IT HAS GONE DOWN
OVER WHAT. I'M HAPPY TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT- I DO THINK
YOU KNOW BARRIERS ARE ARE
COMPLICATED AND SOME OF WHAT
WE'VE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT I
THINK THAT. YOU KNOW SOME OF
THE BARRIERS START WHEN PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES ARE ARE VERY
YOUNG AND- YOU KNOW TYPICAL
QUESTION OF- YOU KNOW VERY
YOUNG CHILDREN IS WHAT DO YOU
WANT TO BE WHEN YOU GROW UP AND
SOMETIMES WE DON'T. ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS. OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND PARTICULARLY
PEOPLE WITH SIGNIFICANT
DISABILITIES AND- AND WE'VE
SEEN SHIPS AND IN THOSE
ATTITUDES WITH- WITH- THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
EDUCATION ACT THE ABA.
INTEGRATION YOU KNOW. SOCIAL
CHANGE TAKES TIME AND DECADES
AND- SO I DO BELIEVE WE'VE
WE'VE MADE STRIDES ALONG THE
WAY BUT- BUT YES THERE THERE
ARE THOSE BARRIERS- THERE ARE
BARRIERS TO- TO INDIVIDUALS-
ACCESSING. THE SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED- TO GET SUPPORT TO ME
AND RE THEM. AND THERE ARE
ADDED TO VERY- IN- WITH WITH
THE NOTION THAT WITH
DISABILITIES ARE UNABLE TO WORK
FOR TO BE PRODUCTIVE AND SO I'M
WORKING ON ALL OF ALL OF THOSE
ASPECTS OF THIS- OF THIS
SITUATION. I HAVE A- I HAVE A
PERSONAL FRIEND WHO HAS IT AS
SEVERELY AFFECTED DOWN SYNDROME
A CHILD HE IS A ARE SEIZE
TWENTY FOUR NOW- AS- IS TWENTY
FOUR. YOU KNOW IT WHEN HE WAS
SIXTEEN HE WANTED TO DRIVE SO
WE TALK ABOUT DRIVING IN THE
COUNTRY IT WAS A VERY EFFECTIVE
BUT- HE GOT TO DRIVE AND THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TO HIM. HE ALSO HAD A
JOB- WHERE HE WENT TO WORKING
IMPACT IS LUNCH EVERY DAY ONE
OF THOSE- WHAT LUNCH BECAUSE
THAT MY GRANDPA USED TO KERRY
RIGHT WITH THE BLACK WHEN IT
WAS KIND OF. THE SHAPE LONG
WAYS IN THE LEAGUE CAME AT- IS
VERY PROUD OF THAT LUNCH PAIL
AND IT TOOK A LOT OF PRIDE- FOR
HIM TO BE ABLE TO GET UP EVERY
MORNING HE SET HIS ALARM AND-
HE GOT READY AND HE WAITED FOR-
THE BUS TO PICK HIM UP SO THAT
HE COULD GO DO THIS JOB. AND HE
HAD SUCH A HIGH SENSE OF PRIDE
TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS JOB AND
AGAIN I DON'T ADVOCATE FOR
PEOPLE TO GET PAID- LESS THAT
YOU KNOW LIKE A LOW WAGER LOW
LOWER WAGE THAN MINIMUM WAGE.
BUT YOUR JOB DISAPPEARED WHEN
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION CITY HAD TO BE
PAID AT LEAST MINIMUM WAGE. AND
BECAUSE GARRETT DURING THE DAY
EVEN THOUGH HE TOOK PRIDE IN
THAT POSITION HE COULD PROBABLY
PRODUCE- LESS THAN 10% OF WHAT
PAIN SOMEBODY OUT MINIMUM WAGE
WAS. AND EVEN THOUGH HE GOT
LESS THAN MINIMUM WAGE IT WAS
HIS MONEY THAT HE EARNED AND-
AND HE TOOK PRIDE IN IT GAVE
HIM A SENSE OF PURPOSE A.
GEERTS HIS PERSONALITY AND
EVERYTHING CHANGED. WITH HIS
FAMILY AFTER HE LOST THAT JOB
HE GOT DEPRESSED HE- THERE WAS
A LOT OF THINGS THAT HAPPENED
SO I THINK WITH THE GOOD INTENT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYBODY GETS
AT LEAST A MINIMUM WAGES IS THE
INTENTION AS WELL. BUT I THINK
FOR PEOPLE LIKE GARRETT AND
THERE ARE MANY OF THEM PROBABLY
IN THE SEVENTY PERCENTILE THAT
ARE NOT WORKING I THINK THAT-
AFFECTS THEM AND I THINK WE
SHOULD LOOK AT. THE SERIOUSLY
LOOK AT THIS IS MY OPINION I
THINK WE SHOULD LOOK AT
SERIOUSLY ALLOWING- INDIVIDUALS
WITH SEVERE DISABILITIES.
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES TO BE
ABLE TO. HAVE THESE OF JOB THAT
THAT. EMPLOYERS ARE WILLING TO
BRING THEM ALONG AND LET THEM
FEEL VALUED AND LET THEM AND
PARTICIPATE. AND EVEN THOUGH
THEY MIGHT ONLY PUT THREE CANS
ON THE SHELF IN AN HOUR- WITH
SOMEBODY ELSE COULD STOP MORE.
OF IT THEY STILL HAVE THAT
SENSE OF PRIDE AND IN THE END
HAVING A JOB- WITH THAT
PARTICULAR PERSON I'M TALKING
ABOUT. HAD A- WHERE THEY CLEAN
TO THAT THE- REST STOPS- THE
STATE REST STOPS UP ON THE
GRAPEVINE IN. THE HE WHO WAS
JUST SO HAPPY TO HAVE THAT JOB.
N. M. SO ANYWAYS AND HE'S DONE
OTHER JOBS AS WELL. AT WILL
WHAT DO YOU THINK. I THINK THIS
NUMBER THE 70% NUMBER IS HIGHER
NOW- THAN IT WAS WHEN I WAS IN
THE- ASSEMBLY. DO YOU THINK
THAT. PASSING THAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WELL INTENDED WELL
INTENDED. AFFECTED PEOPLE LIKE
GARRETT FROM BEING ABLE TO BE-
EMPLOYED. BOTH HER FIRST I'M
SORRY TO HEAR THAT STORY I
THINK I DO I DO AGREE WITH YOU
THAT THAT IT'S UNFORTUNATE- I
WANT TO INDICATE THAT- THE LOSS
HAS NOT PHASED OUT- SOME
MINIMUM WAGE- OR SHELTERED
WORKSHOPS AT THIS POINT- IT I
BELIEVE THAT THE LAW THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IS THE
EMPLOYMENT FIRST BILL WHICH- I
RECOGNIZE THAT IN CALIFORNIA.
BERMAN IS THE FIRST- AND
PREFERRED OUTCOMES FOR PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES- I
THINK YOU KNOW WE ARE PARTNERS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT FELDMAN ALL
SERVICES CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION ON THE BLUEPRINT
FOR- COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT. AND WE REALIZE THAT
THIS IS A REALLY DIFFICULT AND
CHALLENGING ISSUE AND NOBODY IS
ADVOCATING FOR TERMINATING
PEOPLE WITH IDG TAKING AWAY
THEIR JOBS TAKING AWAY THEIR-
INDEPENDENCE AND CRIED- WITHOUT
SOMETHING IN PLACE TO REPLACE
THAT. AND SO I THINK THAT- I
THINK WHAT HAPPENED IS
UNFORTUNATE BUT IT'S CERTAINLY
NOT THE INTENT OF WHAT WE'RE
WORKING ON A STATE DEPARTMENTS
WHICH IS TO- NOT ONLY POVIDE
THE SUPPORTS NECESSARY FOR-
INDIVIDUAL- LIKE GARRETT BUT
ALSO TO PROVIDE THE SUPPORTS IN
THE COMMUNITY. THAT ARE NEEDED
FOR THINGS LIKE- JOB COACHING
AND- JOB SUPPORTS AND SO AGAIN
I I'M SORRY TO HEAR THIS STORY
I AGREE WITH YOU IT'S
UNFORTUNATE I THINK THAT- THAT
THE INTENT AND OUR GOAL IS TO-
IS TO. MOVE TO A PLACE WHERE
PEOPLE LIKE YOUR IT CAN WORK ON
IN THE COMMUNITY EARNING A
SUSTAINABLE LEVEL OF WAGE AND-
AND THAT'S WHAT WE BELIEVE HERE
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION. THAT WE SERVE
PEOPLE WITH THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES AND WE
LEAVE NO ONE BEHIND AND WE
BELIEVE EVERYONE- IF. THEY
CHOOSE TO CAN WORK. THANK YOU.
CENTER LAYERED. WHY ARE THINGS
DONE NOMINEES INTENSELY
QUALIFIED LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING OR HAVE NO QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SENATOR SENATOR BATES.
I WOULD TOTALLY AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES TO MY RIGHT SENATOR
LATER BUT I HAVE TO MENTION TO
MATH WE DIRECT OUR- I WAS THE
BRAND NEW SOCIAL WORKER YEAH
AND NOW NINETEEN SIXTY THREE
WHEN THEY CREATED THE
DEPARTMENT OF. REHABILITATION
AND- WHAT IS INCREDIBLE WE
STARTED OUT I WAS ASSIGNED TO
THE AID TO THE DISABLED PROGRAM
THE ADULT AIDS PROGRAM WE
ACTUALLY HAD TO HAVE TRAINING
OVER ALL OF THE- WELFARE
PROGRAMS AT THAT TIME SO I WAS
A SOCIAL WORK TRAINING I GUESS
YOU WOULD SAY WITH A PSYCHOLOGY
BACKGROUND BUT- WHAT WAS REALLY
DISTURBING WITH AT THAT TIME.
WE JUST WERE ABLE TO GET OF
FINANCIAL SUPPORT. THERE WERE
NOT THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
THERE NOW AND CERTAINLY
HONESTLY DRAKE YOU ARE VERY
MUCH A PART OF MAKING THAT
HAPPEN FOR THESE PEOPLE.
BECAUSE I IT WAS JUST SO
FRUSTRATING TO ME. STRAIGHT OUT
OF COLLEGE TO SEE PEOPLE MY AGE
THAT HAD DID NOT HAVE A FUTURE.
OUR BECAUSE THERE WAS NOTHING
THERE FOR THEM TO TRAIN THEM
AND THEY HAVE ABILITIES MY
MOTHER IN LAW AS A MATTER OF
FACT TAUGHT. SPECIAL ED FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND UP. MANY OF
THOSE WERE OF. PEOPLE WITH DOWN
SYNDROME BUT THEY HAVE FULL
MANY QUALIFICATIONS FOR DOING.
WORK AND FEELING ON THAT YOU
KNOW FELT. OF. TO BE ABLE TO BE
SELF SUPPORTING TO HAVE THAT
DIGNITY OF THAT. SO YOU FAR
BROADER THE LONG WAY AND- GOD
BLESS YOU FOR THAT SO YOU.
CERTAINLY HAVE MY SUPPORT
CHANDOS AND ON THIS IS JUST
BEEN A GREAT DAY WITH THE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED WITH ALL OUR
APPOINTEES IN THIS PARTICULAR
AREA. SO WE ARE VERY VERY
FORTUNATE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE PEOPLE LIKE
YOURSELF AND THOSE THAT WE-
RECENTLY THIS. I GUESS TODAY
INTERVIEWS AT ALL HAVE SUCH A-
PASSION AND A COMMITMENT TO.
YOU KNOW THE VULNERABLE
POPULATION OUT THERE THAT.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO ENJOY THE
THINGS THAT WE- DO NOT HAVE.
THAT MANY CHALLENGES SO THANK
YOU AND YOU'LL HAVE MY- STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SOMEONE
THANK YOU ARE SENATOR BATES
WITH THAT I THINK MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE REALLY COVERED IT AND I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH I
COULDN'T AGREE MORE WITH. THE
COMMENTS OF MY LAST TWO
COLLEAGUES IN TERMS OF- MY
SUPPORT FOR YOU. WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO FOLKS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE APPOINTMENT. OF MISS ME
DIRECT AND A REMINDER FOR
WITNESSES WHO TO PROVIDE
COMMENT VIA PHONE WE'RE GOING
TO PUT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER UP AGAIN AND THAT
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR THE%
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE
SEVEN SIX ZERO NINE. AND WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC OUT TO SEE IF THERE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. I DO'T
SEE ANYONE HERE. IN THIS ROOM
SO WE ARE GOING TO LOOK AT ROOM
ONE TWELFTH. AND SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHED HER APPROACHING THE
PODIUM IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE AND WELCOME BACK.
MADAME MODERATOR- TO TEAR UP
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE IN SUPPORT.
MAN A MODERATOR WE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS APPOINTMENT
AND THEN WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I'M
CURRENTLY AT FOUR IN Q. WE'LL
GO TO LINE FIFTY ONE SO I HAD.
HELLO OUR LINE FIFTY ONE. YES
GO RIGHT AHEAD MY NAME IS
KATHERINE CAMPISI AND I'M A
FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
AND I'M HERE TO OUR- STRONGLY
SUPPORT AND IMPROVE
CONFIRMATION. I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING BUT AT
OCCIDENTAL DESCRIBED TO IMPROVE
AND OPEN UP FOR PEOPLE WITH THE
FACT DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND I FOUND HER TO BE. AND
FASHION. WHEN GET NEGOTIATION.
VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE ALL THE
POLICY ISSUES I AM VERY VERY
COMMITTED TO. AS WITH MOST
SIGNIFICANT ABILITIES GOING TO
WORK. IN ADDITION I NOTE THAT
FOR THE COMMUNITY APART STRONG
WORDS. ACT WELL IT CURRENT WITH
KATE. SHE BRINGS ALONG. LEGAL-
AND ASK WELL AS POLICY. YEAH
THINK IS AB YEAH BUT THE
GATHERED I KEEP WE SHOULD KEEP.
OKAY IT EIGHT OKAY I THOUGHT
AVERAGE BIRTH CANDY FROM. THANK
YOU BOB WE GO TO THE NEXT
WITNESS I HAD STATED EARLIER.
THAT BECAUSE WE HAD SO MANY
APPOINTMENTS THAT I WOULD ASK
PEOPLE TO GIVE THEIR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION THEY REPRESENT AND
JUST THAT THEY SUPPORT AND
GIVEN THE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES WE ARE HAVING. I'M
GOING TO ASK IF THE WITNESSES
WHO ARE IN THE QUEUE TO SPEAK
WORDS SPEAK SLOWLY BECAUSE WE
ARE HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES BUT WE WANT TO GET
YOUR NAME. AND ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT IF ANY AND JUST THAT
YOU SUPPORT SO- MADAME
MODERATOR LET ME ASK YOU TO
QUEUE UP THE NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU LINE FIFTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
OLIVIA RAINER I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF THE TARJAN CENTER. AT UCLA A
FEDERALLY DESIGNATED AND
UNIVERSITY CENTER FOR
EXCELLENCE. IN DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. I AM HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. FOR HIS NEW
TRICKS TO SERVE IN A LEADERSHIP
ROLE. WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION. THANK YOU SO I
CAN NOW MISUSED MA'AM I
APPRECIATE I THINK WE HAVE GOT
YOUR TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT I ASK
FOR- THE YES SUPPORT AND WE
HAVE THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MADAME MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU A LINE TWELVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS LINDA
O'NEILL. WELL KIND I AM
REPRESENTING VANDERBILT STATE
UNIVERSITY. ENTER WORK
INSTITUTE. AND I AM HERE TO
GIVE A STRONG SUPPORT FOR ANTI
MERE DIRECT FOR HER SENATE
CONFIRMATION AS THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY ONE
SENTENCE SHE IS AWESOME LEADER
AND HAS EFFECTED MUCH CHANGE
FOR MANY OF THE STUDENTS THAT
WE WORKED WITH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR
MINIMUM RAIDER IS THERE ANOTHER
WITNESS. THANK YOU WE HAVE TWO
MORE LINES SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWITTER LINE SIXTY YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH. HELLO
BLUEBERRY LAND ARE AN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WITH REGIONAL CENTER
OF ORANGE COUNTY. I WANT TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT- ENDING A
MURDER- I KNOW OF NO ONE MORE
QUALIFIED FOR THIS IMPORTANT
POSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY OUR
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU
A LINE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I AM SU SAWYER. WITH
A CALIFORNIA TRANSITION ALONG
IN. AND I WANT TO EXPRESS
STRONG SUPPORT- FOR ANY
PROFESSIONAL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. BETTA
MODERATOR WAS THAT THE LAST
PERSON IN SUPPORT. I HAVE NO
MORE COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH WE WILL
COME BACK INTO A ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE TO SEE IF THERE
ARE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE
IN OPPOSITION AND ALREADY I SEE
THAT THERE ARE NO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HERE IN OPPOSITION.
R. I ALSOSEE THAT THERE IS NO
ONE- WAITING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
SUBMIT A MODERATOR I'M GONNA
COME BACK TO YOU AND AGAIN ASKS
THAT. ANYONE PREPARED TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION GIVE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION IF ANY THAT
YOU REPRESENT AND YOUR POSITION
IN OPPOSITION SIMPLY. MATTER
MODERATOR THANK YOU GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MATTER MODERATOR- WE WILL-
COME BACK INTO THE COMMITTEE
ROOM HERE AND I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE- LOCATION. THANK YOU-
SENATOR GROWTH HAS MADE A
MOTION TO SUPPORT MAN OF
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GROVE HI I KAMLAGER HIGH
WATER I LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES. HI BATES AYE ATKINS HI I
CAN DESIGN. IT IS UNANIMOUS-
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR OF YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOUR- BEING WITH
US TODAY CONGRATULATIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE WELCOME.
LET ME LOOK TO SEE OUR FIVE
MINUTES WE'RE GONNA TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE RECESS AND WILL BE BACK
PROMPTLY AT FIVE MINUTES THANK
YOU.
I APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
PATIENCE WE ARE ON THE LAST TWO
APPOINTEES AND THAT WOULD BE TO
THE HORSE RACING BOARD MEMBERS
WE HAVE MISTER DAMAC THE DEATH
OF SORRY DAMASCUS CASTELLANOS
AND MISPRINTED DAVIS WHO WERE
WITH US AND I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO BOTH OF YOU FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE PATIENCE- WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THESE-
APPOINTMENTS UP AT THE SAME
TIME SO LET ME GO AHEAD AND-
WELCOME TO YOU BOTH N. I ASK IF
YOU WOULD INTRODUCE YOURSELVES
FEEL FREE TO ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE
THAT HAS SUPPORTED YOU THAT IS
WITH YOU AND AFTER YOU'VE EACH
INTRODUCED OURSELVES GIVEN
OPENING STATEMENTS. WE WILL
THEN GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS AND I THINK I MR
CASTELLANOS WE WILL START WITH
YOU AND THEN GO. TO MS DAVIS
WELCOME. THANK YOU- THE MINUTE
YOU ARE WE CAN HEAR YOU WE CAN
HEAR YOU QUITE WELL GO AHEAD
OKAY- YES THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM THANK YOU SENATORS I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. OUR PRESENT
WITH ME VIRTUALLY AS MY WIFE
KATHY- I WORK AT THE INNER
CHILDREN ANTHONY ALYSSA
SABRINA. AND OUR GRANDSON LIAM-
IS WHAT DRIVES ME TO BE THE
BEST I CAN I CAN BE. AND JUST
FOR A FOOTNOTE BY- OUR GRANDSON
IS HALF IRISH. AND LIVING IN
IRELAND SO HAPPY ST PATRICK'S
ST EVERYBODY. I AM HUMBLED AND
HONORED. TO BE HERE BEFORE YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF
MEMBERS OF THE CRB WITHOUT THEM
THIS WOULD NOT BE POSSIBLE. TO
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING BOARD.
IS AN HONOR AND I THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY I HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THE INDUSTRY SINCE
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE- QUICKLY
REALIZED THE PASSION OF THE
HORSERACING FAMILY HAS. WITH
THE THIS INDUSTRY. IT DID NOT
TAKE LONG FOR ME TO HAVE THE
SAME PASSION ALTHOUGH HAVING
THE PASSION AND THE CONCERN FOR
MEMBERS I HAVEN'T- HAS NOT
PREVENTED ME FROM MAKING
DECISIONS- FOR THE SAFETY. OF
THE HORSES THE JOCKEYS AND THE
INDUSTRY. AS A AS A WHOLE I
BELIEVE MY THIRTY FIVE YEARS
AND- TEAMSTERS UNION
NEGOTIATING CONTRACTS SETTLING
GRIEVANCES AND LISTENING TO
VARIOUS MATTERS- THEY COME
BEFORE ME I WILL- I WILL ASSIST
MY FELLOW BOARD MEMBERS TO
CONTINUE. TO BE OF THE LEADERS
OF THE HORSE AND JOCKEY SAFETY
IN THE INDUSTRY. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME AND-
PURCHASE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MS DAVIS WELCOME. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON PRESIDENT PRO
TEN ATKINS AND SENATORS. MY
NAME IS VERY WASHINGTON DAVIS
AND I'M HONORED TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE
YOU FOR MY CONFIRMATION IS
GOING TO GOVERNESSES APPOINTEES
TO THE CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
BOARD. I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY HUSBAND AND
PHILLIPS AND THANK HIM FOR HIS
SUPPORT. MY INTEREST IN SERVING
ON THE BOARD IS BOTH HISTORICAL
AND PERSONAL. HISTORICALLY I AM
PROUD TO ACKNOWLEDGE NAY
DANIELLE COLLEY SENIOR WAS
APPOINTED CHAIR OF THIS BOARD
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX. AND
HAS BEEN A DRIVING FORCE BEHIND
MY WILLINGNESS TO TAKE ON THE
DAUNTING TASK. OF LEARNING THE
WAYS AND MEETING THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE BOARD.
IT WAS NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
FOR HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN
BATTLES FOR SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
EQUITY FOR ALL. MOTIVATING
PRINCIPLES ON WHICH I ALSO
STAND. AS THE FIRST BLACK WOMAN
APPOINTED TO THIS BOARD I FEEL
THE GRAVITY AND THE HONOR. THE
FOLLOWING AND MR COLLIES
FOOTSTEPS. ALSO JUMPED AT THE
CHANCE TO SERVE ON THIS BOARD
BECAUSE I ENJOY THE SPORT I
THINK THE HORSES ARE BEAUTIFUL
AND ELEGANT ATHLETES. THE
JOCKEYS ARE MASTERFUL RIDERS
AND DRIVERS I REALIZE WHAT A MY
LIFELONG DREAMS WHEN I ATTENDED
THE RACES AT DEL MAR MY SISTER
AND NIECE ON A MILESTONE
BIRTHDAY. WE HAD A WONDERFUL
TIME WAGERING ON THE FORCES
BASED ON THEIR NAMES AND THEIR
LOOKS. THAT SAID MY ENTHUSIASM
FOR THE SPORT IS MATCHED BY MY
CONCERN FOR THE SAFETY OF THE
ATHLETES. AND THE DISTURBING
NUMBER OF COURSE FINALITY IS A
CALIFORNIA RACETRACKS IN RECENT
YEARS. I AM EAGER TO ASSIST
WITH THE STAB WISHING IN
IMPLEMENTING THE REFORMS URGED
BY GOVERNOR TO SOME. OF THE
SAFETY AND INTEGRITY OF THIS
INDUSTRY. THANKS TO MY FELLOW
BOARD MEMBERS AND THE STAFF WHO
HAVE BEEN AT THIS JOB. BY LOWER
THAN I HAVE. MANY OF THESE
REFORMS ARE ALREADY UNDERWAY
AND I AM HAPPY TO BE A PART OF
THE ONGOING WORK. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE- THOSE
COMMENTS AND I'M GOING TO START
WITH YOU MISS- MINIMIZE
CHAIRMAN SENATOR BATES. THANK
YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
NOMINATION AND HOPEFULLY
CONFIRMATION GOING FORWARD. FOR
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BOARD- WE
ACTUALLY INTERVIEWED A NUMBER-
WAS THAT JUST A- BACK IN TWENTY
TWENTY OF AUGUST. NO IN AUGUST
ANYWAY. AND I LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT THE JOB THAT YOU DO AND
AT THAT TIME. THERE WAS A LOT
OF CONCERN ABOUT THE DOUBTS
THAT WERE. ACTUALLY SEEMING TO
MULTIPLY THE FAN IN NEED A TRAP
AND AT THAT TIME. THERE WAS A
MOVE TO CREATE A SAFETY PANEL
AND I KNOW THAT THAT DID
HAPPEN. FOR SANTA ANITA
RACETRACK BAY ACTUALLY- I THINK
FOUND A NUMBER OF COURSE IS NOT
FIT TO RUN IN RACES WAS THAT
SAFETY PANEL OF. ESTABLISHING
AND MY QUESTION ON THAT IN
EITHER ONE OF YOU ANSWER THAT
AND THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE
WOULD BE SPECIFICALLY TO MR
DAVIS. REGARDING YOU DID NOT
VOTE FOR IT EXTENDING THE- LOS
ALAMEDA IS RACE TRACK. LICENSE
PAST SIX MONTHS MAYBE YOU COULD
COMMENT ON. A YOUR YOUR-
CONCERNED THERE IN YOUR VOTE ON
THAT SO LET'S START WITH THE
SAFETY PANELS. ARE WE HAVING
SUCCESS IN GETTING THE OTHER
TRACKS TO ESTABLISH. THOSE THEY
SEEM TO BE. A REALLY GREAT
ADDITION TO ENSURING SAFETY IN
AND REVIEW IN TERMS OF THE- I
GUESS THE ABILITY AND THE READY
NOW SO I'LL FOR THE DIFFERENT.
FORCES TO BE ON THE TRACK FOR
PARTICULAR RACES. AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY. THAT- LOS ALAMEDA MY
STILL HAVE. A YOU MIGHT WANT TO
SHARE THE WITH US IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU FOR SENATE. BATES TO
START WITH THE- THE PANEL IT
DOES APPEAR FROM STAFF REPORTS
THAT WE HAVE SAYING THAT IT IS
HAVING A POSITIVE IMPACT THE
CONCERN WITH LOS ALAMEDA AS
WELL AS WE HAVE LICENSING
AUTHORITY AND- WE- WE'RE- IN
THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING THAT
LICENSE. AND MADE A
DETERMINATION THAT BECAUSE OF
THAT YES RT. THAT WE HAVE
ENHANCED BY MY RECENT SENATE
LEGISLATION. WE COULD LOOK AT
WHAT THE SAFETY RECORD WAS IN
CONSIDER THAT DURING THE
LICENSING PROCESS WE DID THAT
IN DECEMBER AND THEY WERE THOSE
OF US WHO DECIDED THAT WE
WANTED TO KEEP IN A CUL STYLE
LHASA'S LOS ALAMEDA. AND REVIEW
IT AGAIN IN SIX MONTHS I HAD
THE LICENSEE REQUESTED
RECONSIDERATION AND CAME BACK
IN JANUARY AND I MAINTAIN THE
SAME VOTE THAT I HAD IN
DECEMBER. I APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR MOVING WITH CAUTION ON
THAT BECAUSE IT IS SOMETHING
THAT REALLY NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED SO THAT WE KEEP THE
SPORT ALL WITHOUT WITHOUT CRIES
OUT THERE TOO AND THE SUPPORT
THAT WAS I THINK VERY TROUBLING
FOR ALL OF US SINCE IT'S KIND
OF PART OF THAT- THE LITTLE THE
AMERICAN HISTORY IN AND WAY
BACK TO BE BEYOND THAT SO
BEFORE THAT SO I SAY SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT IT MAY BE AND THEN
MR CASTELLANOS ARE YOU MIGHT
SPEAK TO THE- SAFETY PANELS AND
HOW YOU SEE THOSE WORKING. IF
THERE HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
ESTABLISHES SOME OF THE OTHER
TRACKS. THE BASIC DETAILS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SPECIFICALLY
BATTLES THAT WERE ENACTED- HAVE
BEEN VERY INSTRUMENTAL. IN NAY
THIS SAFETY OF THE HORSES AND
YES IT HAS JUST AS YOU SAID IT
HAS BEEN PROBLEMS. THAT PRIOR.
TO RACES AND EVEN POST RACE.
THAT THEY GET LOOKED AT THE
HORSES GET LOOKED AT AND- WHEN
THEY GET A VALUE WAITED. PRIOR
TO THE RACE OF THE EVALUATION
IS. NOT UP TO PAR THEN THEY
WILL BE- SCRATCHED. AND THEN
AFTER THE RACE IF THE AGAIN IF
THERE IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
NOTICED OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT
WITH THE HORSE- ANY TYPE OF
SLIGHT INJURY OR ANY. ANYTHING
AT ALL WOOD- INTERFERE WITH
THEIR WITH THEIR RACING. THEN
THEY WOULD ALSO. ARE GETTING
PUT ON THE LIST SO- THEY WERE
NOT BE RACE IN THE NEXT DAY OR
IN. FUTURE TIME UNTIL THEY
DETERMINE THAT THERE HILL BUT
YES IT HAS BEEN VERY HELPFUL
GREAT. THEN THAT WAS A GREAT
RECOMMENDATION THAT CAME
THROUGH THAT PANEL THAT.
DELIVERS USEFUL THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR SERVICE VERY IMPORTANT
BORRADOR SHARE WITH YOU VERY
QUICKLY WHEN I WAS VERY YOUNG.
MY RELATIVES LIVED RIGHT. NEXT
TO THE SANTA ANITA RACETRACK
WE'D GO OVER THERE AND COLLECT
ALL THOSE OLD TICKET THAT
PEOPLE THREW AWAY. THIS BILL
HAD VALUE. SO ABOUT THAT
PROVIDED A LOT OF YOU KNOW.
BEING ABLE TO GO TO THE MOVIES
AND ALL THAT NOT NOT. ASK MOM
AND DAD WOULD SAY NO BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE MANY. IN WITH
THAT YEAH WE DO. YEAH THANK YOU
SO MUCH APPRECIATE THAT. OR IS
YEAH. THANK YOU MAY VICE
CHAIRWOMAN- SAN LAYERED NOT OUR
REGISTER HAD A GREAT VISIT WITH
BOTH OF THESE- APPOINTEES AND
THOUGHT THEY ANSWERED THE
QUESTIONS REALLY WELL TO MY
SATISFACTION OF GOING TO LOOK
FORWARD TO A SUPPORTING ON HAVE
NO QUESTIONS NOW. THANK YOU
SENATOR SENATOR BREAUX. THANK
YOU MADAM PRETEND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING BOTH OF
THESE NOMINEES AND I DON'T HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH US SENATOR COBBLER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR PRO
TEMP I JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR EITHER OF THEM.
I'M CANDIDATES TO ANSWER YOU
BOTH DON'T HAVE TO- I WAS
WONDERING DOES THE BOARD HAVE
THE ABILITY TO TRACK THE
MARGINS OF THE- FIVE TRACK
OPERATORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. JUST IN TERMS OF-
PROFIT REVENUE BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THAT FIT IN UNDERLYING
DISCUSSION WITH REGARDS TO. HOW
THE TRACKS ARE MANAGED AND- THE
DEATH OF THE HORSES- ISSUES
AROUND SORT OF IF TRAINERS ARE
BEING THREATENED OR- YOU KNOW
THE PRESSURE TO FILL THE
STALLS- YOU KNOW AND SORT OF
RUNNING HORSES TOO FAST TOO
SOON TOO OFTEN- SO I DIDN'T
KNOW IF YOU ALL HAVE THE
CAPACITY OR IF YOU'RE- IF
YOU'RE ABLE TO DO THAT TO KIND
OF MONITOR THAT. THERE IS-
THERE THERE IS WAYS THAT WE DO
LOOK AT THAT AND RECENTLY-
RECENTLY THEY HAVE. COME UP
WITH A WAY OF BEING MORE
TRANSPARENT AND AS FAR AS THE
HORSE DOESN'T RECORDING STUFF
WHERE IT'S ALWAYS BEEN RECORDED
BOTH THE HAS BEEN ALWAYS POSTED
NOW WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT
LATELY- THERE IS A STORAGE
REPORT THAT COMES OUT. THAT WE
SEE THERE IS OTHER REPORTS OF
FINANCES A COME OUT THAT WE SEE
SO YES THERE IS WAYS OF
TRACKING THOSE. GREAT I'M
WASHINGTON DAVIS ANYTHING TO
ADD. NOW I THINK IT IS ACCESS
PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE WE DO RELY
ON THOSE THAT THEY CROSS THE
REPORTS AND OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE ALSO NOW POSTED ON THE
WEBSITE OKAY THANK YOU SO I
JUST WANT TO ADD YOU KNOW MY
ARM. I GREW UP GOING. TO THE-
RACES MY FIRST ONE WAS- I GOT
AN EXACT A WIN AT CHRISTMAS
CARRYING. EVEN MORE THAN.
WINNING JOCKEYS AT DEL MAR-
IT'S- YOU CAN BE A BEAUTIFUL
SPORT TO WATCH. WHEN YOU KNOW
THAT THE HORSES ARE BEING LOVED
AND TAKEN CARE OF- AND THEY CAN
BE HEART WRENCHING TO READ
ABOUT THE DEATHS AND SO MANY OF
THEM- HAPPENING. AND I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE MANY DOESN'T
HAPPEN THAT AREN'T EPORTED YOU
KNOW ACTUALLY THROUGHOUT THE
SPORT ACROSS THE COUNTRY- AND
SO WE JUST HAPPEN TO HAVE. A
SERIES OF REPORTS ON THESE
DEATHS- I THINK IT WAS. A E.
OVER A YEAR AGO THAT MAKE IT
REALLY ALARMING I WANT TO
APPLAUD YOU FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING AND I HOPE THAT
YOU WILL CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO
SHED SOME TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. FOR THE
OPERATORS THAT ARE OPERATING IN
THE STATE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING YOUR APPOINTMENTS.
THANK YOU SENATOR DAN DIED.
COULD HAVE BEEN MORE WELL SAID
I WOULD- REMIND SOME OF THE
COLLEAGUES- ON THIS- SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE NEW MEMBERS- THAT. THIS
APPOINTMENT IS TYPICALLY NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR AND OF
COURSE WE WANTED YOU TO APPEAR
PRECISELY FOR THOSE REASONS
AND- AND SO I THINK- SENATOR
COM LONGER SAID IT PERFECTLY
THAT'S WHY WE'RE INTERESTED
IT'S WHY WE WANTED TO HEAR FROM
YOU. APPRECIATE BOTH YOUR
COMMENTS- MR CASTELLANOS IN
YOUR ROLE. RELATED TO THE
SAFETY AND- MISS WASHINGTON
DAVIS YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT WHY
YOU VOTED A CERTAIN WAY I THINK
IT GIVES US SOME COMFORT HERE.
AT THIS COMMITTEE THAT WE ARE
DOING THE DUE DILIGENCE WE NEED
TO BECAUSE- LIKE YOU- YOU KNOW
I REPRESENT DEL MAR- AND- I WE
ALL HAVE STORIES AND I THINK.
AGAIN SENATOR CALM WATER SAID
IT WELL WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THOSE INCREDIBLE ANIMALS OR-
ARE WELL TAKEN CARE OF AND THAT
WE'RE DOING THE UP MOST TO MAKE
SURE THE INDUSTRY IS ON THE
CUTTING EDGE OF FORWARD
THINKING. ARE SO THAT WE CAN
MAINTAIN IT SO- THANK YOU TO
YOU BOTH. FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
I WILL BE SUPPORTIVE AND I'M
GOING TO MOVE TO- MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO ARE HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. I'M GONNA START
WITH SUPPORT. AND IN THIS ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE- I STILL
SEE THAT WE DON'T HAVE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HERE. IN PERSON.
I'M LOOKING AT ROOM ONE TWELVE
ARE ALSO NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE SO. MADAM MODERATOR I'M
GONNA COME BACK TO YOU. AND ASK
IF THERE ARE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN IN
SUPPORT. AND ASK THAT AS WE
QUEUE THEM UP TO SPEAK THAT
THEY GIVE THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF INDEED THEY
REPRESENT AND JUST THEIR-
SUPPORT COMMENT- FOR THE RECORD
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I DO HAVE TO IN Q.
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THE FIRST ONE OKAY THANK YOU.
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KARLEY
WALKING CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE I TRADE
COUNCIL AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES TO THE G.
H. R. B. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS LIKE
MONEGAN ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES TURF CLUB PACIFIC
RACING ASSOCIATION AND THE
STRONACH GROUP IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE APPOINTEES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MADAM
MODERATOR WAS THAT THE THERE
WERE TWO OR IS ANYONE ELSE IN
THE QUEUE. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- OKAY WE'RE
GONNA COME BACK IN- TO THE
ROOM- THERE OBVIOUSLY IS NO ONE
HERE FROM THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
OPPOSITION NOW. I DON'T SEE
ANYONE HERE I STILL DON'T SEE
ANYONE IN ROOM TWELVE SUBMIT A
MODERATOR I'M COMING RIGHT BACK
TO YOU FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT MIGHT BE ON THE
LINE. VIA TELECONFERENCE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE AND
HELP TODAY MADAM MODERATOR WE
SO APPRECIATE IT. I'M GONNA
COME BACK I TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR AND I'M GOING TO
ASK YOU DO WE NEED TO SEPARATE
THE VOTE. NO NO SO I WOULD ASK
FOR A MOTION. THANK YOU-
SENATOR GROWTH AND- WE WILL. WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR FROM
SENATOR GROWTH TO. SUPPORT BOTH
OF THESE APPOINTEES MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GROWTH WILL GROW BY KAMLAGER HI
YOUR MOTHER I LAYERED HI THERE
I BATES RIGHT I ATKINS HI I CAN
SIGN IT IS UNANIMOUS AND AGAIN
LET ME CONGRATULATE YOU BUT
ALSO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE PATIENCE AND STAYING
WITH US THIS AFTERNOON GOOD
LUCK AND ALL THE BEST. THANK
YOU YEAH THANK YOU. OKAY WE ARE
AT THE END OF THE AGENDA AND-
TO CONCLUDE THE HEARING- LET ME
SAY- THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU
WEREN'T ABLE TO TESTIFY AND TO
THOSE WHO MAY WANT TO HAVE
ADDED MORE COMMENTS TO YOUR
TESTIMONY. LET ME ASK YOU TO
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS. YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOUR SUGGESTIONS
ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOUR TESTIMONY IS ABSOLUTELY
INCLUDED AND OUR OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. SO LASTLY LET
ME THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION AND
THANK YOU TO THE STAFF WHO
RESPONDED SO QUICKLY TO HELP US
WITH SOME OF THOSE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES WE COULDN'T DO
THIS WITHOUT YOU I SO
APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK. SO
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES
ONE ALL GO INTO OUR EXECUTIVE
SESSION THANK YOU.